order number 12 persent to executive
order
204 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing on bills referred to the
committee and scheduled in the house
calendar for today an executive session
may be held on any Bill referred to the
committee please note there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email HCS leg. state.
n.us in the event the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote we'll start by
taking a roll call attendance when each
member states their presence also state
that there's anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to no
law thank you madam chair representative
Alle
Gro what's that your name was follow oh
I'm sorry
Bailey representative
fellows
uh present uh in the room
alone representative Le
branch presid and I am in my room alone
please State the location you're at he
did he he stated it representative
goalie present at home and my wife is in
the other room
representative Gro is here at home in
her office
alone representative Judy not here yet
representative
lenara I am here and I will be Mobile
today and I will be alone okay thank you
representative
leus I'm present and in the committee
room representative
Maguire pres to the committee room
repres representative
Pearson representative Roy here in the
committee
naso representative Santo naso I see you
but I don't hear you well I don't really
actually see you
either okay I'll come back
representative
Schmidt I am present at my home office
Shu I am present at my home in penr
alone except for my cat representative
Schultz present uh in my home in
conquered and my husband Gan Taylor will
be uh in and out of the room okay
representative scitech will be arriving
later
representative
yakovich present at home alone in the
room
okay so just to be sure in the L we have
representative
algro we have representative Maguire we
have representative Roy and we have
representative leus is that
correct
yes okay thank
you all right I have a further an
announcement the last hearing this
morning that is House Bill 631 will'll
have closed captioning available there
is a link to obtain it and we um we will
deal with that when it comes I thought
let people know that the Clos captioning
will be available for that
hearing all right on House Bill 230 I
call Representative MC Williams who is
the Prime
sponsor
good morning and thank you chair Maguire
um it's a pleasure to be here this
morning and to see you all virtually uh
my name is Rebecca McWilliams I am a
representative for the west side of
conquered marac
27 I'm also the mom of three small kids
I have three-year-old Twins and a
four-month-old so uh this bill is near
and dear to my heart because um I am
living child care in New Hampshire so
I'm going to give a little bit of
history about the bill um House Bill 230
uh came out of a study uh committee
which I chaired in 2019 so House Bill
524 uh turned into uh a study where we
had five meetings with the public the
committee was charged to examine the
adequacy of daycare programs and
Facilities across the state identify
issues and impediments to starting
running and growing both Home and
Commercial daycare facilities and also
identify ways to reverse the current
Trend this is 2019 of child care
facility
closures so uh after five meetings and
many many hours of testimony we compiled
a report identifying several of the pain
points to the child care industry on the
business side in hopes that we could
come up with a bipartisan solution uh
this was very much about resolving
issues to make sure that businesses can
survive that parents can get child care
and that the children are safe and of
course it's always a
negotiation uh so in 2020 uh we did
introduce a bill that unfortunately did
not make it through due to covid um it
was actually a series of bills in 2020
and what I've done for the 2021 session
since we're limited on time and this is
all pretty much hybrid or remote all of
the bills that were were introduced in
2020 have been combined here in 2021
into what I'm calling an Omnibus
business of child care bill so the bill
itself really seeks to solve some issues
that were uncovered during the study um
and the
committee uh hearings and findings in
2019 uh the first is coming up with a
procedure that is more fair for
businesses for posting the results of
child care monitoring visits on the DHHS
website and also providing additional
time for business owners to respond to
the Department's
findings uh the second thing is to
reduce the amount of continuing ed uh
required of um professionals working in
the child care industry right now the
number of hours is 18 and this bill
seeks it to drop it to six hours there
were many reasons cited uh but one of
the big ones was because uh there seems
to be a little bit
of difficulty in getting those hours and
also uh for child care employees who
have to pay for their own continuing ed
there is a hurdle to both finding the
time often they are taking care of their
own children in their off time and
paying for continuing aded so we did a
comparison between other professions
that also have a a heightened standard
of um safety uh police officers in New
Hampshire need eight hours of continuing
ed per year and lawyers need 12 hours uh
and then comparing salary of those two
professions to child care uh we felt
that six was an adequate compromise and
that's why it's written in the bill this
Omnibus Bill the way it is um in
addition uh we established the minimum
qualifications for certification as a
child care associate teacher allowing
life experience to count
um there are quite a few individuals who
would be interested in um meeting the
standards but would not be able to
actually attend college level courses
and so this would take life experience
in as um allowable for for being an
associate teacher also we looked at
diversity in the industry and it appears
that while there are quite a few
children who represent minority
populations it's very rare to find an
associate teacher who's a minority and
this may be an impediment requiring the
college level uh
credits uh finally step four we uh
changed some of the requirements for the
appeals process following a dispute
between the state coming in and doing an
audit of a child care um
facility basically uh there was some
concern about uh retaliatory behavior
and whether a facility truly needed to
be closed following uh
a major finding after the state came in
and did an audit and so this is
hopefully to clarify the language in
this bill uh to allow that facility to
remain open until the pendency of the
appeal is
completed and then uh finally the goal
on step five is to study the creation of
a neutral appeals process to review
violations committed by child um Care
Facility uh obviously the concern here
again is retaliatory Behavior
and um feeling as though when someone
comes in and audits a facility the
person who's looking at that facility
may be the judge jury and executioner
and there really didn't seem to be a
neutral third party or a process for
review outside of the state um assigned
staff so that's really what this bill
sets out to do and I'm happy to answer
any
questions thank you are there questions
committee question represent thank you
for recognizing me uh thank you for
taking my question I um I'm just curious
how many total um child daycare center
from your studies daycare centers are
there and um roughly how many Clos in
the past year two
years you know I don't have that data in
front of me and I don't want to give you
bad
data um you know I would say that we're
over a thousand but I can't give you the
actual number for total um and closures
are a little bit difficult to track
because often what will happen is the
facility will close and reopen under
another
name uh so it may not truly be a closure
um so I'm going to defer to the state to
get you that data with some future
testimony yes thank you they would know
questions there's one representative
fellows thank you madam chair there
um representative mck Williams can you
um go over again the professional
development um hours the change in that
and also do you have any um information
that
compares what you're propo what we have
now and what you're proposing to what
other states
require that's an excellent question um
just to reiterate the current
requirement is 18 hours of doing Ed um
and some facilities are able to provide
that for their staff um some facilities
require the staff to do that on their
own time with their own dime um this
proposal seeks to reduce it to six
rather than
18 um I know we looked at Vermont and I
can dig that up for you and get back to
you on that I don't have it in front of
me um but it did appear that New
Hampshire was higher than our
neighboring states I don't know the
exact numbers but I'll get back to to on
that
one thank you um just followup follow up
um isn't the the number of professional
uh development hours is different for
different kinds of Staff isn't it and
are you just changing
one so the the blanket you are correct
there there are two different levels the
blanket change drops everything to six
that's the way it's written um I believe
that part-time under a certain number of
hours is less than 18 I believe it's 12
hours for part-time and once again I'll
let the state um give you the exact
correct data on that um yes thank you
thank you representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair uh
representative Mick Williams did you did
uh uh acquire the knowledge either
through your Commissioner of your own of
your own uh efforts to determine what
the marketplace uh offers uh with regard
to competitive work for um people who
would be potential Child Care employees
in terms of wages and
benefits yes this was something that we
heard quite quite a bit of testimony
about from people who attended the the
study committee hearings uh it appears
that um although minimum wage in New
Hampshire is
$7.25 uh most facilities are able to
offer in a range of somewhere around $ 9
to $15 for child care um
staff uh unfortunately that still seems
to be a bit of a bar to retaining staff
um because some of the retail positions
in the state are offering 15 to 18 or
even 19 an hour so what we're seeing is
that it's sometimes or in in many cases
in 2019 it was awfully difficult to
replace a staff person once they had
left because we were looking to find
someone who already had the continuing
ed credits um and also was willing to
work for something less than say a
entrylevel retail position in their
Community often U so it is a battle to
both find and retain staff and uh as I
said the the study committee was really
tasked with reducing
impediments Qui followup
followup so and and uh in terms of entry
into the workplace uh it sounds
like you know child care workers have
have requirements education wise
training wise uh whereas uh the the
Walmart hypothetically they can walk
right in the
door that is correct and that
is
chair representative
goalie thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my
question did we not have uh a bill
similar to this last year and the
committee found that six hours was far
too
few you are correct on that individual
bill um we were in the process of
negotiating that number up when
kaput followup
followup
and is it true that the committee has
received some testimony from child care
agencies out there uh not wanting to
lower it this slow and that we should
probably be looking at maybe another
number
um I'm open to an amendment on the
number of hours I was open to an
amendment in 2020 I'm open to an
amendment now I think that this is a
negotiated thing thank
you okay seeing no other hands are there
other
questions
Clemen
yes good morning thank you madam chair
um Lissa Clement I'm the chief of the
childcare licensing unit and um the
information I'm going to provide um well
I'll provide this information then I'll
also obviously be open for questions um
the first thing when looking at the bill
under number
one um the we are looking for some
consistency with how the days and
business days are
mentioned in the bill on line8 it states
21 days while line 10 states 15 business
days and we would just recommend that
clear
two line
20 I provided the committee with a chart
um this morning via email which outlines
the professional development
requirements in other states New
Hampshire requires 18 hours for staff
working 25 or more hours and for all
directors and Lead teachers 12 hours for
staff working fewer than 25 hours except
for those directors and Lead teachers
and three hours for high school students
and full-time college students um by the
federal requirements under the um Child
Development block grant act we do have
to require some number of professional
hours per year and but the number of
hours is under the discretion of the
state um to to summarize the other New
England states um only Vermont requires
fewer hours at 15 for all staff Broadley
requirements for full-time staff in
Massachusetts Rhode Island and
Connecticut require 20 hours and Maine
requires 30
hours um when this issue was heard by
the committee last year under HB 17113
there were work sessions with members of
the committee
and the department and child care
providers as child care providers were
split on the reduction of hours out of
those sessions the department made a
commitment to allow first aid and CPR to
count towards those 18 hours currently
that was excluded under um currently
that's excluded under our rules um the
bill was determined to be inexpedient to
legislate noting the work done in the
committee from the Department to revise
the rule and we're working on revisions
of the childcare licensing rules which
will allow for that um as you know with
covid things have gotten a little crazy
so the work on our revision of the rules
hasn't progressed as we thought it would
last year but we are committed and we're
doing that this
year um in addition for professional
development the Department of Labor
confirmed that any number of hours above
what law or rule requires must be paid
for by the employer so if programs wish
to have their staff complete more
professional development it would be at
a cost to them which they are not not
required currently to pay for um many
professional development opportunities
are free or low cost there is the um
Child Care aware of New Hampshire which
provides a lot of ta and training for
child care providers at minimum
cost um moving on to the section
regarding the
qualifications um which are the
qualifications that are allowed to
supervise a group of children alone
looking at line 22 starting there what
is proposed is um for an associate
teacher which is a minimum of a thousand
hours of supervised child care
experience and a licensed Child Care
Program and 30 hours of training in
child growth and development the latter
of which may be documented life
experience um one question the
department has is what is meant by
documented life experience and who's
making that determination is that
determination being made by the program
when they're hiring someone is that some
is that documented life experience
something the department will be
required to create rules around what
that
means um and then also to address
something that many of the committee
members may have seen earlier this week
um there was an article in Union Leader
which implied that all teachers in child
care programs are required to have
bachelor's degrees so in case that is
something that everyone has seen um or
some of you have I just want to clarify
that is inaccurate it um associate
teacher qualifications are the minimum
requirements for an individual to be
responsible for a group of
children and in addition to Alternative
Pathways such as a two-year vocational
childcare technical course or paru
educator um certification through the
Department of Education New Hampshire
childcare licensing rules require
associate teachers to be at least 18
years old and have nine college credits
in either Child Development early
childhood or Elementary education or
other field of study focused on children
with at least three of those credits in
child growth and
development if a program has a candidate
with three credits in one of those
topics they can create a written plan to
obtain the additional six credits within
a year while they work as the associate
teacher and the Bureau of Child
Development and Head Start collaboration
in Health and Human Services funds an
early childhood tuition assistance
program with Grant State College and the
Community College system of New
Hampshire which pays 100% for an
individual's first Early Childhood
college class and three courses um and
three other courses in areas of critical
need so there are up to four classes
that can be obtained for 100% tuition
reimbursement and they also provide 50%
tuition to other early childhood
education
courses um a comparison to our
neighboring states for staff responsible
for a group of children in Vermont what
they term a teacher
associate um each group of children is
led by a staff member who's
qualified as a teacher teacher associate
for at least 75% of the hours of
operation they must be 20 years old and
complete high school and must have a
minimum of 21 college credits in early
childhood and um 12 months of working
with children grades three or younger
they also have additional options such
as an apprenti ship program or a child
care certificate through Vermont
Community College which is 24 credits in
early childhood a teacher assistant may
be in charge of a group of children for
25% of their operating hours in Vermont
and that individual needs to have at
least a three credit College course in
child or human
development or school age care and 12
months of experience and they also have
other options to qualify but they still
require some college level coursework as
an assistant and that person can be in
charge of a group of children for 25% of
the operating hours in
Massachusetts a teacher must be at least
21 years of age have a high school
diploma and have completed three credits
in child growth and development and nine
months of work
experience or have graduated from a
two-year high school vocational program
or have a Child Development Associate
which is also known as a CDA credential
um New Hampshire also allows for a CDA
credential we award that as a Lead
Teacher option so it's higher than the
associate
teacher um Mass allows education to
substitute for experience but not
experience to substitute for Education
um they also require specific areas of
um experience with the age group the
teacher is caring for so the teacher
must have experience with preschool
children when they're teaching preschool
or with infants and todders when they're
teaching infants and
toddlers Maine um has let's see their
grp group leader it which would be the
um term that they use for someone who
can be alone with a group of
children they have to have be at least
18 years old and have either a Child
Development Associate that CDA
credential or six months experience
working in a child care facility with 13
or more children or one year 30 credit
hours of college work including a course
in a child related subject so those are
the three neighboring states to New
Hampshire that obviously compete with
for employers um and that gives you some
information as to what other states are
requiring um in addition addition to
that the department began meeting with
child care providers to hear from them
on any number of issues start last year
while we were in the pandemic we've been
using Zoom um and in December we
scheduled a meeting for next week
February 9th to dis to discuss staff
qualifications we recognize the need to
look to our Rule and hear from providers
what changes are needed and we also
regularly approve waiver to allow for
additional time to obtain the
requirements in order for staff to be
qualified um for sections three and four
of the bill um Department Council Kelly
Tom and chief legal officer Melissa St
sections thank you we have some
questions from the committee sure
representative
Schulz thank you madam chair um first of
all I just want to uh say say a
correction HB 17113 in 2020 the one that
would have changed or lowered the number
of required college credits actually was
not I uh an expedient to legislate um it
was tabled I believe it was uh ought to
pass was the motion we would have
considered had we voted on it then but
then because of Co it died so there's
one um two okay so you mentioned some
states uh the surrounding states to New
Hampshire do you know what their minimum
wage
is I do not know uh for Vermont it's
$11.75 an hour for Maine it's $11 in
Massachusetts it's
$12 um you must know that New Hampshire
doesn't have a minimum wage and it's 725
an hour so for the entry level teacher
associate how much on average do they
in here in New Hampshire yeah I believe
um representative McWilliams spoke to
that she and I would agree with what she
said for a range of $9 to $15 or so that
that would be average for childcare
workers great thank
Shu thank you madam chair uh good
morning Miss Clement um you mentioned
that you have been
negotiating uh the fact of the
continuing hours I was wondering if you
felt that those negotiations are close
to coming to an agreement and what that
might
be so for the professional development
hours um what we are considering because
we did hear strong opinions from both
childcare providers for and against it
the negotiated agreement at that what we
came to with the work sessions last year
was that we would start counting first
aid in CPR much of that training can be
four to six hours so that that would be
an addition of hours that they can now
count towards their annual hours that
they were not able to count previously
compromise thank you we are still Contin
we are still continuing to you know hear
from providers nothing is said in stone
but that is where we're starting from
based on the work that was done last
year followup
follow up thank you um so my next
question is
um would you feel that degrees that are
granted by community colleges which we
all know are a lot less expensive than
uh higher uh schools of Education are
adequate to obtain jobs at these
positions so we're not asking for full
degrees um in order if we're talking
about about the associate teacher
requirements we ask for nine credits in
early childhood so that is the
equivalent of three courses typically at
a community college or maybe four
courses Grant State College Awards four
credits per course so yes so um I mean
that's that's where we're at right now
based on neighboring states based on the
research done that some level of
coursework is necessary in order to
understand children's CH growth and
development and be able to provide safe
and healthy environment for them so
that's where we've started from um but
we recognize that there could be other
ways to obtain that um those degrees and
we have just this year launched the
department a teacher apprenticeship
program and also have we are also now
working with um doing teach program
which helps pay for college coursework
as well and that's being done through
the Bureau of Child Development and Head
Start
collaboration thank you you're welcome
representative
Bara thank you uh Madam chair Miss
Clemens I was on the subcommittee for
the um the the amendment to this bill
last year and at that time you had
mentioned that you were going to be um
adding CPR and first aid to the
requirements to those requirements that
we're going to count to lower help lower
the uh required education so
how much longer would that
take hopefully not much longer we plan
to do that this year like I said we're
meeting with providers next week um in
order to you know flesh out some of
those staff qualification issues um
we're working on revising the rule but
you know how rul making works we need to
have our draft completed and submitted
over to the Joint Committee on
legislative you know joint
administrative committee on legislative
rules and go through that process so I
anticipate by the Fall um if not sooner
but you know it it is a process and our
rules are quite large and we are working
on streamlining them and doing a lot
more than just this one thing because
there are there are other things that
we've identified that we want to address
as well thank
Schmidt thank you madam chair thank you
Miss clemet so I'm glad to see you're
doing comparative studies with regard to
our neighboring states I'm wondering
whether you're monitoring to see whether
our our system is working in terms of
having sufficient labor force available
um to meet the competency requirements
and so forth uh because uh while you've
given us some very interesting
information uh it it it's more
differentiated than just some of the
parameters you've given us so is it
working in New
Hampshire um I'm not sure I'm qualified
to answer that question um I know
obviously are you trying are you trying
to monitor that aspect whether it's
working or not um we're taking
information from the um providers that
we license um and determining what
issues that they are having we are also
noting that it's kind of a chicken and
egg scenario where if providers can't
increase the amount of money they're
offering for staff then it's hard to
attract people to those positions
whether or not um the education
requirements are higher or lower I've
heard from providers that even if
they're putting ads out there and I'm
sure you'll have providers speak to this
even putting ads out there they're not
getting anyone to even respond never
mind whether they're qualified or not
once they do respond and they have a
chance to talk to them so it's I I'm not
sure that the rule is the necessarily
the place to address that our rules are
making sure that the care that is being
provided to Children is safe and
adequate and it's not really a place
where we can look to address the child
care needs which have been going on for
years this isn't a new phenomenon this
is something that's been happening a
long time but we are doing our best to
get our PS pults on that and to see what
we can do thank you madam chair other
committee seeing none I'd like to call
Kelly
Tom
Madam chair um while I'm we have a tiny
arrived he's not in the room with us
okay then I see other Representatives
have uh come in and I've been able to
check them off so I think he's the only
one who has not who's not at the at the
uh Committee
hearing good morning who presentative
Judy is here very good you have thank
you than you
representative
video
yes I'm here you share it with us
definitely
yes Miss
Tom I'd also like to announce my
Hampshire thank you I also put agenda
for all right I don't see Miss Tom she's
in
chair yes you wish to testify I do yes
thank
you good morning Madam chair and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Kelly Tom and I am general counsel
for the Department's child care
licensing unit I appreciate the
opportunity to speak this morning and
wish to touch base briefly on sections
three and four of the proposed
legislation with respect to section
three on page one line
25 the department would simply like to
point out that the inclusion of the
language in paragraph two to allow a
leny the right to appeal and informal
dispute resolution goes above and beyond
the rights of other lenses not just
those in child
care Additionally the department did not
receive a request for a fiscal note
worksheet for this legislation but I
would just point out that there would be
a significant fiscal impact to the
department for this additional right of
appeal this would be an entirely new
process that is unfamiliar to both child
care licensing staff and to the hearings
examiners at the administrative Appeals
Unit and if the committee decides to
move forward with this portion of the
legislation the department would would
need at least one additional staff
position in the child care licensing
unit to handle this new work as well as
one additional hearings examiner in the
administrative Appeals Unit as this is
again not something they've done before
and would certainly add to the number of
appeals being
heard okay Excuse Me Miss Tom this is
three the licens sees and hearings
beginning on line 25
yes thank
you with respect to section four on page
two line 14 this is the section about
retaliation being prohibited the
department is in agreement that there
should be no retaliation against an
applicant permittee or a lensey and that
action certainly should be taken to
investigate any allegations of
retaliation however the department
wishes to propose an alternative to the
process outlined in the proposed
legislation if there is a
concern hearings examiners do not have
the ability to determine what
constitutes retaliation as there are no
rules or laws surrounding the definition
of
retaliation what evidence is required to
prove retaliation exists nor what would
be the appropriate relief consequently
the department suggests that perhaps a
more appropriate Avenue to investigate
claims of retaliation would be for a
report to be made to the commissioner's
office and investigated by the
department in order to take appropriate
action against any Department employee
having found to be in violation of this
section if you have language that says
so please send it to us sure and that
that concludes my testimony Madam chair
I'm happy to answer any questions at
this
time representative Schmidt has a
question thank you madam chair thank you
very much miss Tom um if you were
present at the jail car uh discussion
and hearing uh several years ago with
regard to this specific issue you'll
recall there was quite a bit of push
back from a number of providers uh with
regard to a sense that uh that the
inspectors were sometimes characterized
or perceived as um you know execu well
judge jury and executioner with regard
serial nature of Investigations that
that the Jael car committee was unhappy
about um and so the language that that
you've been suggesting I think uh please
massage it if you haven't already done
so to to uh address that particular
aspect as
well thank
you other
questions seeing none I call uh Miss
ensen
you hi there my name is Jen enin um
thank you for letting me speak today I
am giving testimony and opposition of
House Bill 230 and it is specifically
Parts two and three of the bill that I
opposed
um I have a few points to make um one is
the idea of the trilemma of child care
this is a term that was coined first by
Gwen Morgan um and it speaks to the
compensation quality and affordability
um and to give a little more clarity on
what that
means just pull this up
here
so the trilemma identifies three goals
of Early Childhood programs how to meet
any one of these goals creates conflicts
for the other two the result of the
trilemma is a problem that everyone who
cares about young children must help
solve so if you think about um Quality
depending on knowledgeable experienced
Child Care teachers and providers who
are justly compensated um it's expensive
um and not affordable for many families
compensation for child care teachers and
providers continues to be inadequate in
order to keep programs affordable to
parents and results in low self-esteem
and high turnover of child care teachers
and providers both of which have
negative effects on program quality and
then affordability for parents has
resulted in child care teachers and
providers contributing to the true cost
of child care through their poor
compensation so that was that was
directly taken from um uh
a document that I I will send along to
you when I have a chance to put that
together um but I think that it's
important to think about those two
components of the um requirements
reducing the requirements
for professional development will have a
negative impact on the quality of care
that is offered to children and I
appreciate I I can't remember the name
of the um the individual who was
speaking about comparing the amount of
hours required for
police I I am an early childhood
educator I've been in the field for 20
years I'm currently uh a director and a
teacher I'm actually at my school right
now I just stepped out so I could attend
and give testimony but I looked Instead
at nurses and and teachers um you know
Public School teachers and the required
hours for a a nurse is 400 over four
years and actually let me verify that
yep 400 in four years and for uh a
teacher I have a
um New Hampshire state certification
Nursery through grade three and I'm
required to have 75 hours over three
years um and I think it's important to
consider the idea
that um I'm sorry I just lost my notes
Here
that child care is truly the
infrastructure of our child care is a
critical part of our state's
infrastructure um and this has been
illuminated especially by the current
pandemic um because when when people
couldn't go to work
um our our economy couldn't function and
Care is not just keeping children safe
and out of Harm's Way Learning Happens
the moment of child is born and it's
important to ensure that the people who
are caring for the children have a depth
in knowledge of what is required to
support healthy development I also um am
putting together a written testimony
that I can share as well but part things
that I'm looking at in that are the
um expulsion and suspension rates in
early childhood programs um throughout
the United States and and in our state
and I was thinking
about
uh something that was illuminated
recently um with regard to New Hampshire
schools um I found an article that was
speaking to 8% of Elementary AED
children were suspended or expelled at
the Christal moli School in
2018 and knowing that brain development
is exponential
Fast and Furious during the first eight
years of
life making choices that are impacting
the quality of care at that young age is
going to have a terrible impact on
children going forward and then it will
drain the schools the other I have one
last thing to to point out and then I
will um be finished but I just wanted to
say I was looking at the salaries of
teachers so every teacher at at my
program has a master's degree and we all
choose to work with the youngest
children my salary is about $37,000 a
year and I am a director with 20 years
experience and I teach in the classroom
looking at
the teachers um Public School teachers
currently it's almost double so the
state average salary for a teacher um in
6178876367
um and that you know they're also
benefits and so forth so my major point
is that these two elements should be
taken out of this bill and need to be
looked at with a lens of how we can
develop and sustain
uh Workforce where teachers are
compensated it is Affordable and we can
provide high quality thank you thank you
questions from the
committee
hi good morning and uh thank you for
testifying um and thank you for uh
allowing me the moment to uh to question
uh the witness on you've made a number
of definitive statements um on the
effects of some of these changes and I'm
not going to uh go through each one but
I will point out one as an example and
ask you to please elaborate a little bit
for instance on what basis are you
concluding other than opinion
on what basis are you concluding that a
decrease in hours would uh necessarily
care thank you for that question so part
of this is based on um the understanding
of what is required for professional
development currently the state requires
childcare licensing requires six hours
in health and safety training so if we
go that that's part of the 18 hours so
if we go from 18 hours to six then all
that is required is health and safety
and if I um look
from Child Care aware of New Hampshire
in thinking about choosing child care
and what what quality looks like um it
speaks
to
oh you know here it states associate
teachers must have a high degree um must
have a high school diploma and nine
credits in early childhood education and
it states here that um New Hampshire
requires 18 hours per year of ongoing
training in all I mean in early
childhood education for all center staff
with the idea being that if if you're
just looking at health and safety it's
kind of it like puts me in the police
perspective being someone who is in the
classroom every day if I am only
learning about health and safety I'm
just keeping children safe there is so
much more that goes into Child
quality I mean if you think about the
learning that is happening these are
some of the the indicators of quality so
if you're providing high quality care
for children you're helping infants form
and prolong secure attachments so it's
important to understand what that looks
like um you are
also helping infants with positive
identity formation you are including
families in child rearing practices as
part of care you're treating babies
differently at different points along
their developmental
trajectory thank you you're
welcome no other
baldini good morning can you hear me yes
thank you good morning my name is
Samantha baldini I'm the owner of two
licensed Child Care Centers the Godard
schools in Nashua and dar New Hampshire
I'd like to thank the community for
allowing me time to speak today on the
importance of House Bill 230 section 4
regarding retaliation by the New
Hampshire childcare licensing
unit as a victim of retaliation I feel
that it is important that I speak out on
the importance of improved oversight of
the cclu there are many child care
providers in the state who are afraid to
do so and I hope that my experience will
give them a voice as well section four
is critical to support the child care
industry providers currently have no way
to defend themselves against retaliatory
behavior from childcare licensers who
have unchecked power over them my
experience with a retaliatory visit from
New Hampshire childcare licensing
occurred on November 20th
2019 documentation on this visit in the
form of video and letters from my
teachers were emailed to the committee
this morning on this date two licensers
from New Hampshire childcare licensing
arrived at one of my centers for a
monitoring and visit it's important to
note a few things first a monitoring
visit is scheduled by cclu to check on a
Center it is not due to any complaint or
investigation second two experienced
licensers are never together on a
monitoring visit cclu is tightly staffed
and this activity is regularly completed
by one
licenser thirdly I had previously filed
a complaint against one of these
licensers for insulting a child in my
Center in front of her mother the other
licenser had previously had her findings
of our Center overturned when she was
new to the job as she had grossly
miscalculated ratios incorrectly and
failed to ask for a copy of the staff
schedule to determine her
findings our visit on November 20th 2019
began with the two licensers sneaking
into my building through clearly marked
security barriers they failed to check
in with any management and entered
straight into our infant classroom my
husband saw them and asked them to come
out and meet with him to introduce
themselves they did not want to leave
the room to talk to him and he had to
demand that they do so in this
interaction one licenser actually said
to him quote we can do whatever we want
want we are
licensing they also lied about how they
got into the building as we were later
able to prove with video footage which
has been provided to this
committee we let them continue their
monitoring visit in our classrooms and
we called the head of childcare
licensing to express our concerns the
head of cclu did nothing to check their
behavior and their visit continued in a
manner that was abusive to my teachers
the licensers were regularly sarcastic
and multiple times they singled out
teachers in a classroom using their
bodies to Corner them away from the
children they were they were supervising
and bad badgering them the day was a
nightmare for my entire team as I have
emailed the letters from my teachers to
this committee I will just provide a few
highlights of what they said about the
visit um I'd also like to note that um
when you read this testimony please
remember that these are preschool
teachers infant teachers toddler
teachers they watch children all day
they are not accustomed to conflict
they're not politicians they're not
business owners they're not lawyers um
the things that were put in front of
them were actually very scary and some
of them thought they were going to be
asked to leave or that they were going
to lose their jobs one teacher said
quote it seemed like an
inquisition another teacher said quote I
observed the licensers asking the same
teacher questions simultaneously
interrupting the teacher from
supervising of the supervision of the
children another teacher said I felt
targeted I was questioned repeatedly on
the same topic they took my attention
away from my students they interfered
with a lesson and they completely
disregarded that children were asking
for my help and continued antagonizing
me another said they made me feel
uncomfortable by asking me a lot of
questions in a corner and by doing so
took my eyes away from the children and
my
co-teacher another said they multiple
times asked me if I had any concerns
regarding the way the center was being
run child care providers should not be
in fear of licensers sneaking onto their
property abusing their teachers being
dishonest or either implicitly or
explicitly declaring that they can quote
do whatever they want I ask you to
strongly consider passage of HB 230
section 4 to begin to make progress on
making child care licensing accountable
for its actions Against Child Care
Providers here in the state of New
Hampshire thank
you thank you for your testimony are
committee there being
none
I have a question Mr
chair okay go ahead it's a question of
the chair uh how many additional
Witnesses do we have uh to hear from
this morning on this issue quite a few
hold on
second
okay that's okay you don't have to give
me the exact number we got quite a few
we have to get at it
V
10 g t thank
you all right um I'm G to call Sally
Willen
rer saying that yeah um good morning to
the committee and thank you for having
letting me have the opportunity to speak
today um over the last several years
starting in
17 there were um a number of issues that
child care providers tried to uh provide
input for the licensing rules which were
revised in 2017 and unfortunately I
think a lot of those concerns were not
heard and they um certainly were not
addressed and they have further
compounded the crisis that child care
programs are in um current day and even
further compounded by covid-19 so I'd
like to speak today actually in support
of all of the um articles of this bill
but a few of them I want to speak on
specifically so um the number one thing
is that we are experiencing a critical
Workforce shortage especially during
covid as other participants have
testified that um child care providers
and centers are having a difficult time
recruiting and retaining staff that
leads is because a number of issues um
so one is the
qualifications the minimum of nine
college credits to be left alone with
children um we can't find staff I
personally have had an adout since
October and I have had one candidate and
after offering that person $17 an hour
um she said said that she was going to
decline because she did not want to have
to commit to all of the various pieces
of paperwork and requirements such as
the eligib the eligibility card the
professional development and um you know
this person happened to have the
education credits but I think it's
indicative of the issue that we're
facing seven years ago when I opened my
program I didn't hire anybody with less
than an Associates um but often times my
staff had bachelor's and master's
degrees unfortunately that Workforce
doesn't exist um and is oftentimes not
willing to work for the wages that child
care programs can provide the average
median wage according to the workforce
study in 2017 was
1079 for a um child care worker and um I
would agree that anecdotally the average
wages are probably between $9 and
$15 but the lack of Workforce is driving
up wages and creating a competitive
market where essentially um workers can
cherry pick and also use it to negotiate
and drive up prices so they're saying
well this Center offered me $15 what can
you do and because programs are show so
short staffed they end up having to
offer a higher wage in order to fill
that opening rather than say I can't
afford that because we are also required
by licensing to have children in a
certain number of ratio with those
providers and so we are in a critical
situation where um I was on a call last
week with Early Learning New Hampshire
and um I've been on other meetings with
providers and we are hearing a
resounding cry from Child Care Centers
saying they have families that need care
but they cannot admit the children to
their programs because they do not have
the staff to actually work in the center
um so I think that you know the
qualifications piece of the nine college
credits oftentimes when we look at that
we're also seeing that um a lot of the
espec you know a lot of folks they don't
want to have to take the college cours
workk they may not be able to um balance
that with their schedule they may not
have the funds and although Melissa
clemant spoke about the um the ECE
courses that are able to be paid for
100% by the community college system in
my experience we have had um applicants
for that child care workers and the
spots are limited they fill up quickly
um often times there's only about 50 to
75 spots for them to get that tuition
free and so you know that doesn't really
create that big of an opportunity
for employees to be able to get those
college
credits also looking at professional
development um I have been a huge
supporter of reducing the professional
development hours not because I don't
think that early childhood Educators
should um have continuing education or
that they shouldn't be uh working on
their own professional and personal
growth but I do feel that often times
while many there are many trainings that
are free and online staff are already
overworked their spread thin especially
during
covid they work on average 40 to 50
hours they're often times single parents
who have uh Child Care issues themselves
that they may not be be able to complete
that professional development we also
have whether people may or may not want
to acknowledge this but it is I do see
it as a gender-based issue most of the
child care Workforce is women dominated
and we're finding that a lot of these
employees are in what we call the
sandwich generation so not only are they
trying to care for their children but
also for aging parents and so time is a
commodity
for them and um they lack that resource
in their personal time to be able to
work those 450 Plus hours a week and
then still have the time um to do the
professional development um one of the
speakers was talking about nurses and I
just want to clarify if you go on to the
New Hampshire Board of Nursing it's
actually um she was speaking of a APRN
in active practice and so for for nurses
just to give you an idea continuing
education for an RN is 30 contact hours
in 2 years and an LNA is 24 hours in two
years I would also ask you to consider
the salary and the benefits that these
individuals enjoy um and also the
schooling that's required for an RN and
for public school teachers oftentimes
they work nine months out of the year
they get full benefits they have
taxpayer funded salaries and as it was
pointed out by the speaker often times
their salar is double
61,7 188 as she quoted oftentimes our
employees who are working in child care
programs are making 20 to maybe
$440,000 a year and that's even at
director level so I do think we need to
look at when it comes to professional
development as representative MC
Williams stated that we really need to
to take into account um the difference
of what they're being asked to do what
Their college experience and how much
they're going to make for a salary um
and speaking to the trilemma issue that
the previous speaker had brought up in
order to have quality providers you have
to actually have a Workforce and we do
not have that um it has become a huge
issue for PRS we sounded the alarm in
2017 when we asked uh licensing not to
increase hours when we ask them to
reduce the cost of the eligibility card
which is a plastic card that costs $50
to show that someone has been
fingerprinted all of these things create
an unfunded mandate for the child care
programs and there is an administrative
cost to us um to try to get people
through the door and the fact is is that
they can go to places like Target and
Walmart as previously mentioned and
start at $15 an hour without any of
those requirements or barriers um and I
do think that that has a significant
impact on us so um those are some of the
points about those issues and then I
also wanted to support Samantha
Baldini's testimony um anodally we have
heard over and over again that child
care programs feel like they've been
retal against um as one of the
legislators in a previous hearing had
said to um DHHS staff who said that they
hadn't heard about retaliation well it
stands to reason if your agency is the
one that they feel fearful of why would
they go to you when um nothing seems to
get done I will tell you in my own P
personal experience I had a licenser she
was not my regular licenser at the time
she showed up and um she came in with um
the position of when I asked her who she
was she pretty much said that she was
not new to the program that she was sent
to investigate and close programs down
and that was the first 30 seconds of our
conversation so I think you can probably
imagine how that set the tone for the
rest of the visit so I also support um
the looking at um article number four
and certainly AR arle number five uh it
with terms of creating an independent
review board process and I am concerned
that while
DHHS is looking at what unfunded
mandates or what the fiscal costs would
be for their program um to develop new
policies and procedures
around um creating the independent
hearing review process or looking at the
retaliation that they are not looking at
the other side which is that often times
programs that go forward for the
informal dispute resolution process are
going in front of from what I understand
um they're going in front of the the
licensing Chief DHHS legal staff the
licenser who gave them the violation and
also the um the licenser supervisor now
how you can contest a a violation with
the very agency
um that has given you the violation you
know there's not a lot of opportunity
for neutrality there and many
individuals need to hire attorneys and
so it does come at a financial cost to
the programs and I think that's been
lost um in the licensing rules from 2017
to current day is that the state is not
looking at the financial impact that it
has on programs and as a reminder child
care is needed for the workforce to be
able to have a healthy economy and from
2020 from 2019 to 2020 according to our
New Hampshire fact sheet from Child Care
aware we have had approximately a
decrease of 10,000 Child Care spaces in
our state um and I think that that's
indicative of having programs close or
not be able to accept children because
we don't have the workforce and I think
we're we're really headed for a collapse
and I don't mean to be an alarmist but I
think that's a reality and it may be
well and great that Vermont and Maine
and Massachusetts which I don't think is
comparable um Massachusetts is not
comparable to New Hampshire because of
their
salaries but um I do think that New
Hampshire needs to do what's right for
our child care providers um so that we
have a Workforce in which uh
working class families can send their
kids in um and and we're businesses that
that is a bottom line and we contribute
to the health of the economy as well so
I'm sorry for taking so long and thank
you for letting me speak
today thank you are there any
questions apparently not very
please
good morning and thank you for the
opportunity to address this committee I
really appreciate it so my interest in
this bill relates to my professional
ownership of a soon Tobe opening Child
Care Center up in Conway New Hampshire I
currently own a gymnastics facility
there but also as a Granite State mother
of five including twin little girls who
are just entering their preschool year
so I relate to the sponsor of this bill
in that aspect um from both perspectives
Ives I have concerns about the
unintended consequences this bill could
have on the quality of Early Childhood
Educators responsible for the care and
education of young children in our state
as someone currently interviewing
candidates for employment I'm
experiencing the shortage of qualified
applicants many have spoken about today
and probably many of your constituents
have informed you about in my view the
responsible remedy to that problem is
offering more resources to potential
Educators so they can enter the FI field
well qualified for the weight of the
respon responsibilities they will take
on of course there's also the wage issue
to address we can't afford to pay
quality Educators enough money the
remedy is not putting less qualified
candidates with this precious and
potentially vulnerable population as the
sun is just Rising on their educational
journey to back up slightly when I
decided this Summer that my gymnastics
center would add a licensed preschool I
was a little stunned to learn all the
requirements for each level of
professional in this field initially I
thought to myself do you mean I can
teach a 10-year-old how to do a double
backflip which is pretty dangerous and
complicated but I can't supervise and
help teach toddlers painting playing
learning shapes
Etc so much of my professional life has
been dedicated to providing a safe
quality enriching environment to
Children through my
business still to meet requirements I
enrolled full-time last semester at nhg
to begin earning early childhood
education credit so that I can meet the
requirements for
licensing what I learned was that I did
have holes in my knowledge despite
having worked with since I was 14 years
old I read a lot I study a lot I pay a
lot of attention but I needed those
courses even though I didn't know I
needed them before I took them I
expected it to all be common knowledge
but it was not it was essential that I
took those courses and had that formal
education it will make me a much
different director and educator because
of the coursework I've taken I would
encourage the committee maners to read
the entirety of the naeyc Professional
Standards and competencies for early
childhood education S I think there's a
disparity in what we think childhood you
know education should look like and what
daycare centers sometimes do look like
in the state of New Hampshire many of
these standards are best met with formal
coursework I do endorse the existing
stepped option where the state allows
applicants with three credit hours to
enter into a written agreement to
complete the remaining six over the
course of the year one consideration
might be to allow all nine of those cour
hours to be completed in the first year
if they enroll at first opportunity this
would be far less of a dramatic change
to the requirements but give Child Care
Centers the larger pool of applicants
they are
seeking I do acknowledge that there are
a variety of non-public schools and
licensed childcare environments that
give folks relevant
experience this should be considered by
licensing where I disagree with the
language of this bill is that it cannot
substitute for formal cours work in
early childhood education they're not
the same I think it should be used as a
means for granting a waiver of
experience that then allows the
applicant to accumulate the required
experience hours over the course of
their first year of credential
employment again that expands the
potential Workforce it is been my
experience that the department already
currently operates with very reasonable
clear expectations and a willingness to
find a pathway to credentialing
applicants that should be in classrooms
with children based on their experience
and education there is no need to lower
these standards by
Statue finally as a mother of twin
little girls with very different needs I
have to say even with our current
standards in place there are not enough
quality preschool environments in our
communities I have a child with profound
neurological issues and special needs
she deserves to be in a preschool
environment with Educators who have
minimally taken formal coursework
related to children with
exceptionalities all children deserve
for their Educators to have taken
coursework related to Preparing an ideal
environment and delivering effective
curriculum they also deserve for their
Educators to be truly upto dat with
continuing education six hours is
insufficient I say that as the person
who will be paying my staff to complete
their continuing education hours so I
don't take it lightly all children and
families deserve quality standards from
our state for their and from the centers
that take our preschool and child care
dollars with a promise to take good care
of their children's safety and
yes
yes I think the committee uh froze I
don't see
anybody I think the committee room
froze I think we're okay it says the
ahead can you hear me
okay yes okay just in in closing I feel
that in exchange for the preschool and
childcare
dollars we should be promising to take
good care of children's safy and their
educational needs please don't lower the
standards for this field we should work
together to find other remedies for the
workforce shortage and wage issues that
do acknowledge exist thank you so much
offline I can see representative Roy
I can't I don't see I don't even see
it the committee room G room is gone
yeah right let's just wait a minute I'm
back hello everyone if you can hear me
our committee system is suddenly went
down so if everyone could just stand by
well we try to get it um back up again
apparently the the whole complex is
having some connection issues yes we
figured that out yeah the staff internet
connection went out but the guest
Internet connection appears to be okay
so I signed off I was booted out up here
but because you were a co-host you the
meeting's still there um I've I have
reported it to it and that's all I know
so I'm back on as a guest on the guest
Internet
yeah I'm not sure representative Maguire
can be heard perhaps representative Roy
could um recognize the next
person we have H technical assistance
here let's see if if that doesn't work
we'll see what we can do going forward
maybe I can take over for my
laptop thank you time for a little break
for what it's worth I'm also online with
another committee and they also have
lost part of
their
um folks on the committee so apparently
true well in that case what about them
Bruins
Hey so uh I just spent an hour and 45
minutes of my life that I'm not going to
get back uh in trying to navigate
through the labor committee to get their
Zoom to
function that's where I was too they're
having yeah they're having a hell of a
time yes that the zoom is still open the
Public's still on it so it's only us
here in the in the in the office that
mind Mr Vice chair do you want to
continue with the public because uh at
them um representative Schmid I can't do
that because the people who are here are
unable to hear or interact with the
public and ask
questions yes I know that is a
[Music]
well
second going to do a a sound
check this is a sound check can everyone
hear me yes yes
I believe we can excellent sorry for the
technical problems the uh other
committees have been having worst ones
so uh Miss Roberts had you completed
your
testimony I'm not sure at what point uh
people stopped being able to hear me but
I think if I could just offer the last
couple of lines of my conclusion again
that would be great please do
so uh all children and families deserve
quality standards from our state and
from the centers that take our Pres
school and childcare dollars with a
promise to take good care of children's
safety and their education please don't
lower the standards for this field we
should work together to find other
remedies to the workfor workforce
shortage and wage issues that I do
acknowledge exist thank you so much for
your time thank you are there questions
you I don't see
are you not there I'm there but I don't
see her as an attendee unless she's on
the phone I don't even see any phone
numbers so we're going to to skip
minutes
okay Jessica Carver
then good morning members of the
committee thanks for allowing me to
testify today I'm Jessica Carver I'm a
resident of Nottingham New Hampshire I
work in a licensed and nationally
accredited Early Childhood Program that
serves as a lab school for our state and
today I am speaking as a professional in
the field and also as a parent as a I am
a consumer of Early Childhood Services
my four-year-old daughter is in her last
year of programming at the UNH child
study and Development Center we've been
very fortunate to have her placed in
that program since she was about 14
weeks old as we both work full-time in
my
family I do want to briefly bring
attention to the comparison of law enfor
for ment PD requirements so in July 2020
members of the New Hampshire Commission
on law enforcement accountability
community and transparency recommended
to actually increase the mandatory
training hours for La officials to 24
Hours by 2020 and that report's actually
available on the governor's website I
bring it up right now just because it
was spoken it was talked about before um
and I think that that highlights the
forward progress that other community
public servants are um making with
respect to drinking so a little over a
year ago I did testify on a similar bill
that aimed at reducing professional
development requirements for
Professionals in the field my stance
Still Remains the Same I'm in direct
opposition of this particular Bill
specifically the two sections that speak
um to the 18 hours per year being
reduced to six hours per year and then
the associate teacher
qualifications the last time I testified
uh one State Rep suggested that I was
seeking a Utopia that essentially didn't
exist and today I still stand here and
still believe in that Utopia for young
children in our state I I won't waver in
my support for actually increasing the
standards for educators Early Childhood
is far too important of a time period
And as a parent I want the best for my
child I also believe that every child in
this state deserves High highly
qualified Educators that understand and
know how to support the rapid growth and
development that occurs in those first 5
years of life um sadly we don't have
enough time today to really break down
and discuss all the complexities of the
current state of Early Childhood in this
short um but yet long hearing there are
so many issues related to equity and low
pay for educators lack of access to
Quality Care for families lack of
professional requirements and these
issues have been around for decades I
started working in the field at 18 I'm
about to turn 4 next year and sadly we
are still talking about the same issues
with with very little progress so I do
understand the implications of covid but
um and and the impact of that on centers
but we're we're still kind of going in
circles around the same issue children
are our future they are the future of
our economy and society and reducing the
staff qualifications related to
education and PD is only going to
further exacerbate the issues that I
just mentioned above there's a severe
lack of public investment in early
childhood compared to public school
which has already been spoken about on
this call we really need to focus on
advocating for investment in the field
not reducing qualifications for an
already underqualified field I'd really
encourage individuals proposing bills
such as this to really channel the
collective energy to find solutions to
the issues that we have above and engage
with experts in the field experts that
understand and know Child Development
and we should really start talking about
career Pathways for people in the field
Financial incentives to support
Professionals in programs that are
already struggling to make ends meet I'm
going to close with a quote from JFK
quote children are the world's most
valuable resource and its best hope for
the future end quote I respectfully urge
everyone to really stop undervaluing the
care and education of young children we
can't ignore this our children deserve
more and um I really appreciate that you
all listen to My Testimony today thank
you
are there any questions from the
committee I just wanted
to representative Roy um I just wanted
to um as as your representative ning him
I want to thank you for taking the time
Cowell
call thank you how do you do nice to
meet you all I'm uh Jackie Cowell from
Early Learning New Hampshire I'll be
very brief our organization um signed up
as neutral we are a Statewide um
organization uh where we have an we're
an association many childcare uh and
Head Start programs are our members and
you know folks are on both sides of this
issue in terms of you know um making it
realistic and having the right number of
hours so that you can actually hire
staff and then also not bringing it down
because of what you've heard testimony
around that really you know having a
qualified staff is important and a
stable staff so you know I think we are
definitely um in support of number five
of of having that study committee look
at an an appeals process that might have
like a peer reviewed like other
Industries um in ter we think that's a
terrific thing but just really
quickly it really in those first five
years where a lot of children there's
over um about three quarters of children
are in some kind of a Child Care Program
right now as they're because their
parents are working so it's it's doing
two things it's supporting the parents
ability to work but it's also shaping
the workforce of tomorrow uh you may not
realize that if you do the math a child
can actually spend more hours in child
care before they enter public school
then they will their whole public school
from kindergarten to 12th grade
including lunch and recess because again
moms and dads are working they'll drop
off the child they'll commute they'll
work they'll commute back those hours
add up and that's the time of really
important Child Development so Child
Care is really important and having
great teachers is really important at
the same time talking about Vermont and
Massachusetts and Maine they have a lot
of different Investments not just a
different minimum wage they really
invest in helping those programs meet
those standards so I iterate what others
have said that qualified and stable
staff is critical to running good child
care programs but it takes dollars
because right now it's the parents who
are are paying for this mostly it's most
of the one of the reasons you have low
salaries is because it's the parents who
pay for it and they're just starting off
in their careers too it can often cost
as much as sending your child to um to
college to you know Public public
colleges and they're just starting off
in their career they're not 20 years
into their career when they're paying
for this so there's a saying teachers
can't afford to stay parents can't
afford to pay they there's got to be a
better way so I really thank you for
turning your focus on this I'm I like
Jessica and others have been doing this
for for me it's been 31 years here in
New Hampshire I'm sorry that we're not
better off in terms of having a child
care system that allows you to hire
great people and keep great people and
have parents be able to afford it but
I'm not sorry we're still talking about
it I am glad we're still talking about
it and I thank you for this thank you
thank you questions from the
committee
Maran
me
hello I'm sorry I think I'm having
technical issues no I can hear you oh
good okay thank you very much for
allowing me to speak um I hope others
can I'm marann barter I'm the executive
director at Mirch daycare service and
blueberry Express Daycare in Pittsfield
in conquered um I wanted to speak out in
support of this bill I understand my
colleagues and their concerns about
quality of staff and um I wanted to just
give a little bit of background of how
we got into this mess to begin with um
in several years ago the New Hampshire
Department of Education
defunded um The Early Childhood programs
in high school technical schools and the
effect the ripple effect that's had on
the career path of Early Childhood
Educators in New Hampshire is astounding
so when that was defunded although they
did overturn that decision by the time
they overturned it the damage had been
done and a lot of these programs had
been dismantled at marac Valley daycare
service I have 30% of my staff who
started in the early childhood programs
in Tech schools and high schools and
that formed a career path where you
would have these two years programs you
would go on to your community college
and receive some college credits and you
were really well set up for a career in
early childhood education and that path
doesn't really exist anymore and
unfortunately now when someone comes to
me saying you know I'm interested in
early childhood education I'd like to
start out I like working with kids what
I have to tell them is okay you can work
here you can't ever be you can't be
alone with kids until you get college
credits I'm going to pay you $12 an hour
and in your free time you're going to
have to go to school or they can go to
Target and make $15 an hour and do
whatever they'd like in their free time
and unfortunately we are losing out on
that I would like nothing better than to
hire people who have college credits I
would it would fill my heart with joy
but they are not out there to hire and
my hands are tied I don't see any
benefit to Early Childhood programs not
existing anymore because we just don't
have a Workforce something really has to
you
it looks like we' Roy we've lost the
committee room again yes we've lost the
committee
room oh can they hear us miss
Marling I think representative Roy can
hear us because he's on his device but I
don't representative Roy can you hear
us yes I
tell if we just tell Miss bartard or H
to just wait for a moment until I do
have a question for her yeah I have
contacted it um okay let's sit tight
right let's sit tight and um I know that
you know it's again it's systemwide so
it's hard for them to be everywhere at
once they're outages in the L in every
Zoom
EX
[Music]
it looks like we have um the committee
room back in
point
and if if you can change to be the
speaker you can do would you switch to
speaker
view
right representative Shu if you can hear
me ask your question yes yes thank you
um I just wanted to ask um Miss barter
she had
mentioned um I believe the year that the
high school and technical school
programs were defunded and I didn't
catch the year
I'm sorry representative I don't have
that year I um I could certainly get it
for you but I believe it was eight years
ago and um there was a lot of activism
in the field to reinstate those programs
they are an important part of our career
path but by the time it was re by the
time it was reversed it was too late
thank
much
chrisan
Baron I'm sorry
um chair um Maguire I did have a
question
of yes
Miss please ask your question thank you
U Miss barter with the reinstatement of
these programs these early childhood
education in technical schools well
first of all are they back in operation
and have they
helped um they're not most of them are
not back in operation so it created this
sort of funny ripple effect where the
Department of Education chose to defund
these programs um and and they were
dismantled relatively quickly and it
actually it happened at Kind of a Funny
time um we found out in April of the
school year they would not be returning
for the fall and so there was kind of a
Mad scramble
to um change the funding and kind of
work out what would be funded instead
and they ended up funding teacher
preparation programs which were really
for K through 12 and so unfortunately
even though the Department of Education
did reverse and say yes you can in fact
have early education programs that will
be funded through the Department of
Education through Perkins funding um all
by that point most high schools had
already dismantled their um lab schools
their I mean it was just too late gotten
rid of their
staff thank you certainly representative
O'Brien uh thank you chair um and thank
you for taking my question uh you did
talk about uh closing of some of the uh
uh high schools and stuff like that but
how does your industry feel about a
student that continued with their
education uh perhaps uh at the Technical
College not really getting a degree but
taking a certificate program in such a
on this subject uh would they be uh you
know would that make them more
attractive for
higher yes certainly they would but
unfortunately part of the ripple effect
of the high school programs is that many
schools no long many higher education
institutions no longer have Early
Childhood programs either I believe
Plymouth has gotten rid of theirs Rivier
has gotten rid of theirs it is just not
an attractive career for young people
right now unfortunately um I would like
to State though that the state of New
Hampshire our colleagues at Childcare
licensing and at DHHS have several
initiatives that they have proposed to
help fix this problem um apprenticeships
the teach program um and they're great
programs I think we're really excited
about them they're going to take a long
time to implement and so really what we
need is a bridge until we get to the
point where some of these programs can
be implemented I I don't know if the if
the legislators would consider a if they
really can't support this 100% maybe
sunsetting this giving us five or six
years for a little bit of recovery
before these programs could um come back
strong would be a huge
questions thank you Miss Miss barter
Emily
Johnson good morning are you able to
hear me yes thank you thank you madam
chair members of the committee uh for
the opportunity to testify my name is
Emily Johnson I'm the New Hampshire
State manager for Save the Children
Action Network and I have the honor to
represent over 3,000 supporters and
activists across the state of New
Hampshire that are a part of our
bipartisan movement um to be the
political voice for kids uh uh
prioritizing early childhood education
uh
domestically uh save the children Action
Network we believe all children deserve
access to highquality early childhood
education since 2014 we have worked in
partnership with community volunteers
policy Advocates and state legislators
to improve accessibility and quality of
new hipshire child care and early
learning programs while well intentioned
we believe sections of hp230 are a
threat to the high quality of care our
children deserve which is why I'm
testifying in opposition to this Bill
Early Childhood educators are
responsible for the care and education
of our youngest citizens uh while they
provide an essential service to Working
Families and help shape the leaders of
tomorrow they are routinely undervalued
hp230 seeks to answer this shameful
undervaluing of teachers by lowering the
bar for continuing education hours
required of childcare employees by 23s
from 18 hours annually to six hours
annually Early Childhood Educators that
I've worked closely with in my role
understand that their jobs have not
gotten easier but more difficult as our
state copes with multiple crises
impacting children including the opioid
epidemic and the covid-19
pandemic more children are coming into
their care with adverse childhood
experiences or Aces associated with the
aforementioned crisis I believe that
that means we should um child care
providers should be supported by the
state with more resources and training
to help them provide highquality care
answering these crises by diminishing
standards of care would be a grave
mistake that would negatively impact
generations of granite Staters even
setting Public Health crisis aside the
quality of care of our children is a
direct reflection of the competence of
the Early Childhood educator and we
should not consider compromising the
health and safety of our children under
any
circumstances additionally hp230 aims to
loosen child safety regulation by
allowing Child Care programs that have
been found by the state to pose a threat
to the health or safety of the children
in their care to continue operating
during the pendency of any proceeding
for the review of of the decision of the
department unless explicitly ordered to
close as a representative of an
organization that prioritizes children's
health and safety above all else I
oppose any law which would allow our
children to remain in an environment
that is potentially unsafe um so in
conclusion I urge members of this
committee to vote in expedient to
legislate on hp230 as it's written thank
you for your time and consideration of
mine and others testimony today I have
emailed a written copy of this testimony
to the committee ad address and I'm
happy to try to answer any questions you
may have thank you we we did receive
your testimony are there any
questions seeing
none good
Ranos thank you can you hear me okay yes
thank you wonderful thank you so much
for taking time to hear my testimony
this morning in opposition to section
two and three on HB 230 my name is Lisa
rampus I am a resident of Allenstown and
I have been in the field of Early
Childhood for over 25 years as a teacher
and administrator a trainer and mentor
and as a college faculty member in all
of my years in the field one trend has
remained consistent and that is that
teachers in the field face face an
uphill battle from day one they are not
viewed as teachers unless they teach in
K to2 schools they are inadequately paid
and they are ill equipped for their role
in many ways not only are their minimal
standards required to become a teacher
unlike the professions that are being
compared to Early Childhood in this bill
but programs themselves are not set up
in a way to provide the needed supports
to their teachers directors often have
to spend time themselves in classrooms
covering for staff shortages or breaks
throughout the day and they too often
are not fully prepared for their role as
many programs seek someone with
education to meet the minimal
requirements but rarely are able to seek
someone whose leadership or
Administration experience in the field
this lack of experience impacts our
teachers efficacy with young children
while this might seem as a long-winded
and perhaps disconnected testimony the
point I'm trying to make is that
individuals need more training not less
they need coaching and opportunities to
engage in Knowledge and Skills that
align with an action plan they can
Implement with the support of their
leadership who can assist with resources
and modeling as needed as Educators we
teach children to be lifelong Learners
and it's critical that we are learning
right along with them as new science
comes out regularly about the impact
that adults have on young children 's
brain development social emotional
health and their ability to be
successful in later
years this bill could increase the
negative effects on children by allowing
even less trained and experienced people
to be responsible for young children the
children of New Hampshire deserve to be
in high quality programs with educated
and experienced teachers there's a
plethora of research that cannot be
ignored that that proves this yet there
is continued effort to decrease these
requirements it takes a significant
investment from our state to bring this
to fruition
I would be remiss if I did not also
acknowledge that all of this is true
without the added strain of the pandemic
which has placed incredible pressures on
programs and many if not all have
struggled with staffing issues related
to illness quarantine and their own
family commitments such as supporting
remote learning for school age children
many people are trying to keep their
doors open and this impacts their
livelihood while this has been a
Monumental challenge decreasing the
requirements for a person to be able to
work with young children is unacceptable
in our state
I urge you to consider the long-term
impact that these changes would have and
I believe as an expert in my field would
be detrimental to Children it takes a
seasoned teacher to understand and
implement the best strategies when faced
with challenging behaviors that may be
exhibited from children as they try to
make sense of things that cannot be
easily explained like the pandemic we
need to provide more support to these
programs consider Workforce Pathways and
take advantage of the many successful
strategies that are already in use
across our state and make them available
to all so that the children of New
Hampshire can Thrive and be successful
contributors to society thank you so
much for your
time thank you are there questions from
the
committee seeing
none that was the last of the people who
signed up to speak is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on House Bill
I
attende
[Music]
did yes
Miss misser wer Weber thank you for for
asking but we have already heard from
you and view of the fact that we're
already an hour late I'm not going to
representative Shu you had a
question actually a question of the
chair um if there are no further
speakers I was wondering if you would
share with us the numbers of folks who
signed up on this bill either in favor
post representative Shu that information
was sent to you and all other members of
committee this morning you have as much
information as I do thank you I
apologize I was dealing with a u
snowblower repairman before we
met ah some things always take
priority I will search that out later
thank
you all right in that case I am closing
the hearing on House Bill to we will not
immediately
and I open the hearing on House Bill
377 relative to the authority of the
Fire Marshall to Grant an exemption from
fire code requirements in recovery
houses Madame chair may ask if
representative scitech is ready to take
over he is he is okay thank youed
up one hearing that hearing was enough
to give you full credit for
okay I do not see the sponsor she's in
the room Erica Johnson oh please I call
speak um I'm sorry I think you might me
representative Connors this is Erica
Connors I'm the uh Prime sponsor of HB
377 thank you you CAU my mistake please
proceed representative Connors thank you
so much I'll try to be a little bit
quick for you I know you've had a long
morning uh my name is Erica Connors I
represent Hillsboro 15 Manchester's Ward
8 thank you madam Shar and committee
members for allowing me to come before
you today I'm here to introduce HB 377
an act relative to the authority of the
State Fire Marshall to Grant an
exemption from fire code requirements to
recovery houses this fall I chaed the
committee to study State and Municipal
Authority governing recovery housing I
see representative Pearson is here as
well he was part of that committee this
committee recommended that legislation
be submitted to mirror the amended
version of HB 311 from the previous
session that easily passed the house but
died as part of a large omnus bill at
the end of last session the committee
also recommended that the legislation
include a clear definition for Recovery
housing that is what HB 377 does a
recovery house or Sober Sober Living
home as they're sometimes call offers
those in recovery from substance abuse a
bridge between impatient rehab and
living on their own in New Hampshire
there are some great facilities working
to Aid those in recovery providing rules
structure requiring ongoing therapy and
have a drug-free environment they are
crucial in the road to recovery New
Hampshire needs recovery homes to
continue to operate in our communities
and to help people to succeed in
recovery this legislation is no way
designed to reduce or eliminate true
recovery or Sober Living homes which are
valuable and necessary to our
communities in Manchester and other
municipalities however we have found
that there are others who are simply
taking advantage of those in recovery
there are those who are using the
designation recovery house or sober
living home to get around Life Safety
codes associated with hotels Apartments
boarding and rooming houses and are
doing so for greater profits
firefighters responding to overdoses at
these facilities are doing so at high
rates and upon entering are finding
drugs and alcohol everywhere their
finding four people to a basement room
with no second point of eress
non-working smoke detectors and other
major hazards that are hazards not only
for the residents but also for our
firefighters and First
Responders these Bad actors are
operating businesses with no goal of
aiding and Recovery they're using the
designation to circumvent Life Safety
codes and taking advantage of a
population at risk those in recovery
from substance abuse are protected
population under the federal American
with Disabilities Act but right now they
are not being protected this bill does
not interfere with that act as it is a
permissive piece of legislation allowing
true recovery homes to operate under
less stringent regulations than boarding
and rooming houses this is necessary as
there is a shortage of true recovery
homes in New Hampshire and we need to
help these facilities find a path to
safely operate I am aware that great
work is being done on voluntary
certifications but it is not going to
stop others from using the name to solve
life safety issues this Bill defines
recovery housing so that those using the
title of recovery house or sober living
home in order to circumvent those safety
codes and making a profit at the expense
of the health and safety of others can
easily be detected and determined to not
be a recovery home ask that you vote
ought to pass on this bill to help
protect those in recovery and give them
a true chance at recovery as well as to
protect our firefighters and First
Responders who are currently finding
themselves in dangerous situations due
to the lack of clarification on what
recovery housing truly is I thank you
for your time and I'm happy to answer
any questions you may
questions I don't see any questions from
the committee so thank
you well representative Schmidt sorry do
you have a
question uh thank you madam chair I I I
got my hand up just at the last second
uh so I for I have a question of
Representative Connor um have you uh
have you seen the Fire Marshal's letter
to the
committee he sent it to me this morning
and asked me to forward it to the
committee for him yes so you have seen
I we have seen it I whether you've seen
the letter and approve of it and and
agree with it yes yes we are on the same
page he and I work together in putting
this legislation together thank you for
confirming that thank
you
okay I guess I just have one question
representative leus uh yes we also got a
testimony from uh Hampshire Coalition
recovery residences I don't know if
they're going to speak going to speak
okay um so if the if the sponsor could
be a could be available to answer
questions after that that
you Paul Paul pery the State Fire
Marshal good morning Madam chair can you
hear me okay yes thank you great good
morning Madam chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is Paul
paresi it's my privilege to serve as
your State Fire Marshall and uh House
Bill 377 as you know would create a
statute that allows our office to Grant
recovery residences an exemption to
certain requirements of the state fire
code this exemption may be granted under
the following conditions that they are
in compliance with the voluntary
registry or they are certified by New
Hampshire core and in addition they
would have to meet a list of safety
requirements and fire the fire
department would have access for
inspection
annually as uh as many of you are aware
we've been working together with local
fire departments in particular the
Manchester fire department as well as
numerous stakeholders in the recovery
community and DHHS for a number of years
now um trying to find a solution to the
issues that surround balancing Fire and
Life Safety with reasonable inexpensive
access to recovery residences it is not
lost on us uh those of us that are in
fire service that the number of Overdose
deaths in New Hampshire far exceed the
number of deaths that occur in
residential structures here in our state
while we anxious to help in reducing the
number of Overdose deaths we certainly
don't want to tip the scales the other
way therefore we urge caution to those
involved in this issue to ensure safety
in all aspects the New Hampshire State
Fire Marshals office supports this bill
for a number of reasons one it
standardizes the way our state handles
recovery residences from a fire safety
perspective two it may reduce the number
of not in my backyard issues that arise
because the law will be clear number
three it it strikes a reasonable balance
between life safety and access to
recovery residences four it leverages
existing infrastructure such as New
Hampshire core and the variance process
outlined in safe c6000 and finally it
shines a bright light and it is
transparent relative to the extent of
compromise that we are willing to give
and it allows the general court an
opportunity to decide if it's
appropriate for the State Fire Marshall
to be issuing an exception under these
broad conditions appreciate the
opportunity to testify and I would add
Madame chair that it is uh with the
utmost respect that um that we have
worked with the recovery Community um
side by side with this issue and
including New Hampshire core and even
though we may differ on the particulars
of this of this bill uh I do believe
that uh everyone in this issue has the
the safety and well-being of those in
recovery and substance use disc disorder
at the Forefront in their mind so thank
you for the opportunity and it be I'll
I'll certainly be here to answer any
questions thank you are there questions
committee yes I have a
question yes representative O'Brien was
first no
problem uh thank you uh to the chair and
thank you Chief good to see you again
and thank you for taking my question um
on the bill on the first page uh line 20
which is say basement's Living Spaces
shall have an exit uh directly the uh
grade and then it says uh at least one
uh the next J farther down one Escape
window in each sleeping area and in your
familiar
arity to uh basements some of the
windows aren't small so uh are small and
not really can uh be used for means of
uh agress does this go
with the existing fire cold La as far as
basement thank you for the question
representative O'Brien and uh and yes it
it does and you know what we want to
avoid is having someone in a basement uh
sleeping area essentially behind a
closed door having a fire outside of
that uh room and then not having any way
to escape so um we need to they need to
have a second means of erress so the the
window out of the sleeping area sleeping
room is is uh is important to us and it
does correspond with uh with the
existing uh code okay thank
you representative
Schmid thank you madam chair so uh Fire
Marshall good very good uh to see you
this morning or not to see you but to
hear you um and I'm wondering with
regard to the annual inspection uh uh
paragraph of your letter uh I read your
the rest of your letter and agree with
it but uh to me it doesn't strike me
that uh that it should say at least
annually I I'm I'm fearful that we may
get in a situation if we say annually
that uh that that will be insufficient
uh would you be amendable to uh
rewarding
that thank you for the question
representative Schmidt and certainly you
know at least annually is fine with us
um we just we were cautious to make sure
that we're not uh creating a 28a issue
and saying the fire departments must
inspect but if uh as long as access is
uh permitted you know at least annually
that's fine with us followup follow up
so uh thank you um so Marshall uh the
the thing is that you know uh that the
people who are who are trying to comply
will do everything they can to keep
complying uh but the degree that we say
annually uh the people who may be
inclined to slip shot stuff I I know
you're not going to permit anybody who's
clearly trying to skirt the law and and
and abuse the the the provision s for
their own Advantage without regard for
the recovery aspect uh they're bad
actors and you're going to shut them
down but I just think that uh that
neglectful have question representative
leus um thank you and thank you for
taking the question we've Gott a letter
from NH core and there's uh one sentence
in there that I'm concerned about uh it
said many of the requirements appear to
exceed the applicable standards of
existing state law for dwellings um
please I'd be happy to representative
thank you for the question so I I I I
don't want to speak for um for the
executive director Kim Bach but um but I
think what what they are referring to
there is that in existing one and two
family dwellings in our state right now
um sprinkler sprinklers are not required
and uh and in in fact some of these
other uh things that we list out here
are not required either uh there is no
uh requirement for fire drills there's
no requirement for uh you know a
properly maintained cooking appliance uh
no smoking you know obviously we don't
regulate those things in one two family
dwelling so I believe that's what she is
um you know likely or the the NH core is
referring to um um but we don't
necessarily view these uh you know of
course depending on the occupancy we
don't necessarily view these as as
single family dwellings we in some cases
view them as apartment buildings we may
view them as congregate living we may
view them as lodging and rooming you
know depending on the construction of
the building the number of folks that
are living there um in almost all cases
um either beds or rooms are being uh
rented out um and money is being
exchanged so um you know I think that's
probably why she is saying that and I I
don't disagree with the statement that
certainly there are things here that are
uh over and above that but please don't
interpret what she says she'll be
speaking
next just quick followup follow and and
um so you know does the uh do you
basically see a need for every one of
these requirements for this to be
you uh well if we are going to this is
only if we are going to make an
exemption from the fire code so there
may be times when there isn't an
exemption that's necessary in which case
this wouldn't apply but if
the applicant is is coming to us looking
for a reasonable
accommodation um or a an exemption uh
from uh a sprinkler system for instance
then it's our job
to um look at what equivalencies could
be put in place to um not to to allow
them to operate without a sprinkler
system and so that's why we've put in a
number of things that we feel is if if
if these particular things are in place
um and uh and and we're able to verify
them on a at least an annual basis then
yes we we believe that um this this is
these are necessary okay thank
you okay other
questions all right thank you call
Kim
kimb um can everybody hear me all
right yes
okay thank you well good morning members
of the committee um thank you for your
your time to speak about this issue I'm
Kim boach and I'm the executive director
of the New Hampshire Coalition of
recovery residences and I'll refer to
that as NH core to make it easier for me
um I'm here to speak in opposition of
House Bill 377 on behalf of people who
live in recovery residences in New
Hampshire we appreciate the work that
has been done on this and the and the
work of the sponsors F Marshall PRI and
town fire department as as Fire Marshall
pzy said we're all concerned about the
safety of people who live in recovery
homes however NH core opposes HB 377
because one the Fire Marshall already
has the power to Grant
exemptions under current state laws and
two because on its face HP 377 is
discriminatory so let me give you a
little bit of background about NH core
we're a very young organization that has
been certifying recovery residences meet
a
national um minimum nationally
recognized standard of operation and
Care we've been operating that for about
18 months when this legislation began
under previous House Bill 311 NH core
was a Grassroots organization that was
just coming together we've now grown
grown into a full nonprofit corporation
and have certified 18 houses in New New
Hampshire New Hampshire Corp was
appointed by the commissioner of DHHS as
the organization to certify recovery
residences according to those nationally
accepted best practice standards
established by the National Association
of recovery residences also known as
Nar certification is a really rigorous
process that starts with a review of all
the corporate documents and all house
policies and procedures the national
standards set best practice guidelines
for the best interest of the person in
recovery all obligations and
responsibilities for both the operator
and the resident must be clearly laid
out there are also strict guidelines for
the physical structure of the house NH
core visits the house no less than two
times for the initial
certification and at least annually
after that to ensure that safety
standards are in place this includes
adequate square footage in the bedrooms
in the house itself adequate egress
smoke detectors fire extinguishers
regular vac evacuation drills Naran is
available there's adequate bathroom
space and the list goes on and on we
have 36 different standards that we
apply NH core shared a list of our just
our safety regulations with the Fire
Marshall and the Manchester fire
department recently and the response was
that they were impressed and reassured
by our list of of
requirements it's important to note that
NH core Certified Recovery houses follow
an Evidence based social Model A family
type structure there are not boarding
houses there are no locks on bedrooms
bedroom doors nobody can walk in and
just get a room there's a rigorous
screening process to ensure that a
person entering a recovery residence
fits within the family of the house NH
core Certified Recovery residences are
drug and alcohol free any Resident found
with drugs or alcohol is removed from
the house immediately all residents must
be actively engaged in in their own
recovery substance use is not tolerated
recovery homes are safe places for
people to lean into their recovery over
an extended period of time and to learn
how to reintegrate into into society
over the next year or two recovery
houses are not a place to stay for a
week or two they're a place to live for
a year or two until the person has has
developed enough recovery Capital to
move out onto their own and be a
productive member of
society there are two major issues with
House Bill 377 the bill is unnecessary
because the State Firearm Marshal
already has the ability to Grant the
exceptions provided for in this bill and
the bill separates out a subset of a
protected class of individuals people in
recovery homes from active addiction
living in the NH in NH core Certified
Recovery
residences and I'd like to have Chris
Wellington join me we wanted to combine
Our Testimony Chris is a um a valued
member of my
board she's recently retired and
well-respected New Hampshire fair
housing attorney and she's the former
commissioner of the State of New
Hampshire humans Rights
Commission oh excuse me I don't see
where this
organization
it it's your organization is one of the
options not the only way to be
house I'm sorry could you repeat
that you said that this discriminates
against Discovery houses certified by
your
organization however it discriminates
against people in
recovery it sections out as a a subset
of people in recovery housing and that
subset is people people that are either
on the registry with the state or they
are in New Hampshire core certified
housing that doesn't include private um
corporations that don't need the
Assistance or regulation of the state or
of NH core um that does not include
Oxford
houses um it doesn't include anybody
forward
thank you I think uh you wish to
add
yes Christin Wellington yes
yourself good morning Madam chair and uh
members of this committee um I think
Kim's covered our basic concerns really
well I I just wanted to um expound a
little bit on the protections that the
Ada and the federal fair housing act um
provide the Fair Housing Act I'm going
to focus in on um
protects uh members of of uh classes um
by requiring neutral laws applied
neutrally but the proposed legislation
specifically targets housing for members
of a protected class group as as Kim has
said and that is racially discriminatory
and it it it's impermissible under the
law um in 1988 the US Congress added
disability as a protected class to the
federal fair housing act and in its
discussions and in its legislative
intent it was particularly concerned
about protections applied to congregate
housing it was already in 1988 um a
potential worry for them and so that
there's specific language in their um
in their deliberations about protecting
people that were living in in congregate
housing um in 2016 um the US Department
of Justice and um Housing and Urban
Development issued guidance um for uh
land use uh and they specifically talked
about um group homes and that I think at
the time they were calling them sober
homes and we differentiate ourselves a
bit from being a sober home
but that that they were uh indeed
included in the the land use protections
so um there's this idea that many times
uh well-intentioned
um laws and ordinances and regulations
um Target protected class groups based
on
stereotypes um we do feel that the body
of laws in New Hampshire both state and
in local um are sufficient to address
the legitimate concerns of our
governmental structures for Bad actors
in in the field people that are taking
advantage people that are not um
complying with basic uh uh health and
safety laws um that there's there's
also um the fact that recovery homes um
span is is uh Fire Marshall paresi me
mentioned different kinds of residenti
residences so um this isn't a one um
size fits all each each U particular
home um may be subject to different
requirements but many should be
considered as single family dwellings
and that's clear in the case law and
that's why we oppose this this statute
it targets a protected class group and
it's you know just facially
discriminatory
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee yes R isite would you
identify yourself
please oh sorry I'm Christine Wellington
I am a member of the board of New
Hampshire Corp I am a retired attorney I
um was the director of the um fair
housing project at New Hampshire legal
assistance um and have practiced in this
years
O'Brien thank you chair um I'm going to
give you the example you mentioned
discrimination and it kind of tweaked me
a bit so I'm going to give you the
example if I lived in an unattached
single family home uh by the fire code I
can choose not to have any type of uh
smoke detector or sprinkler system in my
dwelling although I would possibly
benefit from my homeowners insurance
however if I was Liv living in an
attached
duplex uh I am required to have at least
smoke detectors in my dwelling and the
reason is the actions of one of the
neighbor next door to me could have
adverse effects on myself and my family
so by having this how do you really say
that it's discriminatory because where
you have unrelated type of people living
in a in a communal type of uh
environment uh and something should go
wrong uh to me this really enhances
their own personal safety going back to
uh like in the duplex situation can you
uh tell us tell me how you feel about
that yes it the the thing that we're
focusing in on is neutral laws U applied
neutrally are not discriminatory but
when you select out a group of people
who are protected by anti-discrimination
laws and say and for you you're going to
get special um uh laws and rules uh that
that require you to do different things
um Fire Marshall paresi did mention that
um in this proposed legislation in
exchange for uh an exemption from in
installing a sprinkler system um the
operator would have to agree to several
conditions that are not required under
existing state law that wouldn't be
required for another non-recovery home
situation that was that was similarly
situated except for the fact that they
weren't recovery homes so singling out
recovery homes for for more uh
enforcement more regulations is the
resolution thank you madam chair thank
you representative I have just learned
that we will lose our captioning service
and signer for House Bill 631 at
12:30
therefore with the permission of the or
the agreement of the committee I am
going to
recess this
hearing immediately open and recess the
hearing on House Bill
369 and open the hearing on House Bill
Services um so hold hold your
horses we will resume this this hearing
at after the completion of House Bill
217 this
afternoon so I I hate to do this but we
are relying on outside services that we
don't normally
need all right so close yes thank Peter
I know you have a question but I think
hearing I you I hear you saying we're
coming back so I'm okay with that right
closing I'm recessing the hearing on
377 opening and immediately recessing
the hearing on House Bill
369 and opening the hearing on House
Bill
631 and Madame chairman may I post the
notice um on the screen share just to um
provide information about how the link
to the captioning can be
obtained yes please do do so I apologize
but
okay that appears to be Representative
Steve
Pearson okay well Madam Madam chair I've
reached
I've reached him on the phone he is
Steve just
yes
available are you seeing the closed
captioning notice we are oh good I'm not
but I'm glad you
are I am excellent I'm I'm seeing the
general court website for some reason
but
um I believe the public is seeing it I'm
sure you're right I just
uh representative Pearson are you with
[Music]
US Representative Steve Pearson would
you oh I'm certainly not against
you could you introduce the bill and
yes
[Music]
hello
hi I uh um I was just posting the um I
just saw her and oh there she is moved
somebody else moved the C is in Lorie
Jola I don't
Jola under
JS
[Music]
um Steve is J
ly unless she's captioner oh Jola is the
other interpreter we're getting that
worked out right now just one moment
there's somebody found
her yeah okay
bye okay are are the
necessary sign language folks and heart
of hearing Folks up and
running yes I believe so
I Lori
Anda there are two
signing
wonderful uh
Pam the representative Mark Pearson
should be logging in so you're going to
see him on the on the attendees list
out thank you madam chair on behalf of
uh representative Mark Pearson you've
opened the hearing on hille
I am reminding myself to slow down when
I
talk for the benefit of
those that do need
interpretation so excuse me
representative Pearson and others we
actually do not need you to slow down so
if you will just it'll be fine thank you
all right I can I can talk fast well I'm
not encouraging you to speed up either
down this uh this bill is a result of a
of the de and heart of
years and I cannot do it justice in the
introduction of this as representative
Mark Pearson has been the chair of that
for several years I'm on the meeting
thank
please thank you very much um for the
record this is representative Mark
Pearson representing Bingham County
34 I am the chairman of the health human
services and elderly Affairs Committee
of the house and also chairman of the
New Hampshire Commission on deafness and
hearing loss and I hope this is Bill
631 yes oh good it's been a strange
morning all over an act relative to
regulation of interpreters for the deaf
deaf blind and heart of
hearing two years ago it was my honor to
be appointed by Speaker shortliffe as
one of the two Le legislative
representatives to the New Hampshire
Commission on deafness and hearing loss
at my first meeting I was elected
chairman and last Friday I was
reappointed by Speaker
Packard the commission represents
various parts of the deaf and heart of
hearing community and representatives
from State agencies charged with
disability rights and representatives
from nonprofit advocacy
organizations I charged my commission
with identifying various deaf and heart
of hearing needs that could either
become proposed legislation or
suggestions to departments for changes
in rules
one item identified was the need for
various changes to be made to the laws
governing American Sign Language
interpreters the national Professor
professional association for these folks
was consulted so that our language could
be brought into Conformity with their
language and the language of various
State
associations a bill was presented to the
legislature last year the house passed
it but as we know with many other good
bills it didn't make it through the
Senate process that bill with minor
changes is the one before you
today many of the changes are minor we
have added the term de blind
demonstrating our recognition of this
subgroup within the deaf and heart of
hearing Community names of various deaf
and heart of hearing advocacy
organizations that are no longer in ex
existance are to be removed from the
law As We examined the State sign
language interpretation in New Hampshire
were two things we wanted to do to
strike a balance on the one hand we
wanted to toughen up the response to
licensed interpreters who violate the
code of professional conduct there is
already suspension or loss of license we
wish to ask add an
administrative fee or penalty but on the
other hand we wanted to provide a
process for those who make many many
mistakes but not the kind of mistakes
which rise to the level of a violation
of the code of professional conduct the
language I wrote in the bill would allow
for remedial action and not punitive
action in these cases
finally we recommend that certif IED
credential interpreters be used when
possible but we know that in some cases
they're not
available in those cases we certainly
make allowance that individuals who are
not yet certified or credentials could
be used in such situations where they're
needed provided they do not present
themselves as being credentialed and
certainly that volunteer signing the
1115 mass for Deaf parishioners would
not have to have a license so that's my
bill and I would be happy to take any
committee
Brian thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my uh question just an
overview um if a student is in school
and does have uh a license uh uh
interpreter well somebody that can do
sign language but in the situation of
the teacher or and or the parah who
complements what the student is learning
this does not affect them am I correct
that is correct CH for Brian thank you
[Music]
none
I'm here could you repeat that please
chair the last your last remark came
through
garble I was calling Jody
leart I'm here can you hear me chairman
yes I can hear you okay Madam chair and
committee members thank you for allowing
me to speak today my name is jod lefor
and I was part of the committee that
worked with representative Mark Pearson
that is to draft this proposal I did
submit some written testimony so I will
try to keep my oral um testimony brief
I'm here to testify in support of this
bill as repres representative Pearson
had mentioned we did have a proposal on
the table last year that passed through
committee but with all the craziness
that happened last year it did not pass
through the full legislature this may
have been a good thing since I believe
that we have created a better proposal
than we had last year some of the
changes are simple corrections as he
mentioned that need to be made While
others are more systemic that we believe
will strengthen the license law allowing
the system to better meet the needs of
all those involved some of those
highlights are the critical shortage
exemption proposed in 326
i7 for qualified individuals that are
not licensed perhaps from outside of New
Hampshire but could meet the need the
pool of licensed interpreters cannot
providing a chance for people to get the
most appropriate match without needing
to go through the waiver
process speaking of the waiver also in
326 i7 bringing interpreters working
under a waiver under the jurisdiction of
the license board gives the recipient of
services a safety net in case an
egregious error is made by the waved
interpreter the grievance procedure
proposed change in 326
I15 is what re in regards to an when
there's an issue between the deaf deaf
blind person and The
Interpreter and often the grievance
procedure is too difficult to navigate
that person may choose not to use that
interpreter again resulting in left
serve is available and The Interpreter
may go on with a behavior without
knowing it was an issue and not knowing
it needs to be corrected even though
mediation has always been an option in
the rules our hope is that allowing this
to happen without the burden of a formal
hearing will make the system more
accessible and more
effective I also would like to pass
along a message of support from the
president of the New Hampshire
Association of the deaf who was unable
to join us today thank you for your time
and I would be happy to answer any
questions committee members may have for
questions okay seeing
good hi can you hear me yes thank you
excellent um good morning members of the
committee um or I guess good afternoon
by this point um thank you for giving me
the opportunity to speak with you today
um my name is Jules good I am a late
deaf person living in New Hampshire and
I'm also here on behalf of my employer
Northeast Sten heart of hearing
services um I am absolutely in support
of this bill I think it's great to be
honing in on um the you know the
processes for lure and everything having
to do with that for the interpreters in
our state I think holding them to a high
standard is really great because um I've
seen my fair share of not so great
interpreters um and so it's great to be
um holding everybody to a standard that
is really going to result in the best um
and most accurate communication for deaf
people like me um one thing that I
wanted to um start my video I can do
that hi one thing that I wanted to um
suggest um is in line 17 of the bill um
where it starts detailing the
organizations that this committee will
um or that this board will consult with
um there's a number of organizations
listed um and we at Northeast Deen heart
of hearing services um would like to be
added as um
[Music]
a a a an organization that this board um
collaborates with um we are kind of the
One-Stop shop for um de and heart of
hearing services in the state um we're
very ingrained in the de Community um we
do a lot of work and offer a lot of
support um to our community and we think
that it's important to be um in the loop
about what's going on with um
interpreter licensure and certification
um so we would like to be added um as a
named member um of of in this list of
organizations that the board is
Consulting with um so thank you very
much thank you are there questions from
the
committee
muchi you uh don't absolutely need to
ask every person a question but you're
recognized for
one well thank you madam chair so um I I
have a question as a former uh
professional interpreter and and uh and
and uh translator I know that mistakes
can be made I've seen examples of work
done by people who are not competent uh
and they're pretty disastrous uh so I'm
wondering how do you deal with this
situation because unless you have
somebody listening to the sign language
interpreter uh and observing and seeing
mistakes being made how are you going to
know unless there's certain obvious
situations but how are you going to know
that the person is not competent
about are you asking me yes oh okay
sorry I was not sure um yeah that's a
great question um so as a deaf person um
I guess it depends on the situation that
I'm in um so sometimes what will happen
is I can see I mean I tend to voice for
myself so I don't deal with this a lot
um but if I am signing and I see that
The Interpreter has said misrepresented
something um that I was signing to them
and I catch it in the captions I'll call
them out on it um and ask them to
correct me um but I think um in
general it it can be hard um
to um to identify like every single
error if you're the only person in the
room who knows sign language and you
can't hear what's going on so you have
nothing to compare it to I do think in
my experience what tends to happen is um
you know we're only really concerned
when there's a pattern of behavior and
mistakes um from interpreters and that
news gets around quickly in the deaf
Community um you know we know which
interpreters we want and which ones we
will take as a last resort um to put it
in a respectful way um and so it is kind
of a matter of
um of seeing a repeated pattern of
mistakes um rather than you know trying
to catch somebody making one small
mistake if that makes
sense thank
you representative
Pearson hi Representative Steve
the this the bill Creator uh does not
have a problem Jules with the request
that you made and will be bringing
forth uh an amendment to add
you awesome thank you very
much are there other
questions okay thank you very much for
your testimony is there anyone who
631 seeing none I will close the hearing
have you want to break now and get back
okay fine we will be
recessing all right the meeting and
resume at one o'clock with the hearing
3:45 I said 377 will resume after
217 that is what you said so that's good
we still also have House Bill
369 right that'll be that was also
recess till till the end okay thank you
madam
chair Madam chair just for clarification
what is the first bill you will be
taking up after the
break the scheduled 1:00 Bill House Bill
345 mushroom
you
notice absolutely it'll be up in a sec
thanks thank you Pam if you're are you
there I I am here will this be uh
despite these technical difficulties
will this be uh on
Facebook uh not on Facebook but on
YouTube I'm sorry you I'm sorry YouTube
because it was a trick question I can
tell never never we'll talk about it
later uh the uh reason I'm asking is
I've missed some of the titles and
commissions and stuff that people were
on and I'd like to be able to review
that that's all sure and you might um
you'll you'll see that the um list of
testifiers was emailed to you and that
that has a number of the organizations
if if a person entered it of course it's
there I will get that between my
Nigerian prince offers
okay just given it another
option and also too if you need uh if
you need a little help with that Mark
will certainly assist you in getting
that
correct hey
Steve Steve is that um what's behind you
at first I thought it was a scene from
war
games I'm currently sitting in the uh
Mission Control Operation Center for
Apollo 14 which by the way is today 50
years ago today would be uh have docked
with the LM and on their way down to the
moon at this
point good stuff very good although War
Games would have been cool
too hey I'm an 80s movie Nut so I love
it
absolutely can you tell me real quick if
the screen share is looking good yes
except that you your symbol showing
oh there we go thank you
embarrassing I always have them on I
like
them I am thankful Pam that Edna is
going far better than labor today that
that room just fell apart um they didn't
even get underway until 10:20 and they
joh j
e
[Music]
it's
Pam if you you can hear me we're seeing
screen
baby
one
yeah that's yet another case feral
government was federal
Federal
for like some of the other LIC so music
insurance people push for that take
anywhere in country that's
right that would require thinking and
B
the
state
representative Pearson
fine hi baby
bles so I don't know what it is with the
microphone on the computer you're using
but your voice is always very muddy and
understand how about now is it still
bad y it's better it's a little better
when you're far back but it's still a
problem
I turned my speakers down is this
better that's that's a little better
close
okay I got this computer at the dollar
store so I'm
not
and well worth it y yeah
starting I mean if you're going to be
attending that way long term I'd suggest
uh getting a USB headset after um it
might work a lot better they don't you
get one for under 30 bucks
yeah
okay I'll do that I've got spare ones
like bring it you're welcome to yeah I
mean I I work remote um full-time for 15
years and uh yeah I always use one of
those a lot better it's much clearer and
you hear much better this is the
mushrooms
yeah representative ker is modeling uh
the one of those for us right now yes
right there in fact I got the wireless
kind uh which is nice that means it's a
little bit more money but it's uh I
don't know how's in fact how is my sound
quality I don't know how I sound okay
sounds fine yes it's fine you also can
adjust your input volume sometime we had
somebody the other day input volume was
too high and it came up they cut the
input volume then they were they were
could be understood that's another issue
too that can be there you know go to
your
settings yeah I finally got one of these
it good to see a lot of familiar
indeed Miss Marling we haven't gotten
the testifiers list yeah
that's we haven't got it yet so exp but
at this point it's been one o' I was
open the hearing on House Bill 345 and
represent the sponsor representative in
our thank you madam chair good to see
you again too um okay so this bill is
House Bill 345 for the record I'm
representative Jerry kerk I represent
Carol County District 3 this bill is a
product of the 2019 mushroom foraging
commission which was charged to study
developing a system for licensing
individuals who forage for wild
mushrooms with the intent to sell them
to restaurant suppliers or at farmers
markets now the issue is that without
passage of this bill restaurants grocery
stores farmers markets and farm stands
will not be allowed to sell or serve
wild mushrooms in New Hampshire the
reason for that is that according to the
2017 us food code in order for a food
service establishment to serve or sell
while de harvested mushrooms in the US
they must be approved to do so by a
regulatory Authority with jurisdiction
over the food establishment and that
approval requires the appropriate
identification of the Wild mushrooms
being sold or served in New Hampshire we
do not have a program for certification
or registration to ensure proper
identification making the sale of wild
harvested mushrooms therefore not
allowed now food establishments include
restaurants grocery stores suppliers
Farm stands farmers markets this bill
does not interfere at all with somebody
wishes to H uh to harvest wild mushrooms
for their own personal use and likewise
I if they just share it with friendss
that would not be harvested be
prohibited either with this now the
difficulty with misidentified mushrooms
can range from Simply a mushroom that's
not edible to one that's toxic and the
toxic reactions can be things like minor
gastrointestinal distress but it can
range up to kidney and liver failure and
death so it's really important to assure
that the mushroom being sold is actually
the mushroom being represented and is
safe to eat a restaurant which serves a
dinner of inedible mushrooms or is the
source of an outbreak of mushroom
poisoning would really sustain quite a
bit of damage to their reputation and an
outbreak of a mushroom poisoning would
give wild mushrooms a bad reputation
harming harming the competent foragers
so the foraging commission recommended
that in order to meet the US Food Code
the state of New Hampshire should
Institute a program for certification
and registration of individuals who
either Harvest identify or distribute
wild mushrooms with the intent to sell
them to food establishments or to
private individuals as food the this
bill was introduced as hb1 1692 in 2020
it passed through environment and
agriculture in the house then went to
Edna passed out of Edna 15 to4 last year
as an ought to pass with an amendment
but then it died a covid death as the
session ended now I had a lot of details
on this bill and the testimony that I
provided to you in advance including
also the the bill the amendment which is
a very minor Amendment we'll talk about
in a moment and also the the report of
the mushroom foraging committee Mission
I'm not going to go into all those
details I put it there so you could just
follow it but the bottom line is that
under this bill DHHS would be
responsible for approving an educational
course for individuals who wish to
harvest identify and distribute wild
mushrooms and that educational program
will cover identification harvesting
handling storage New Hampshire RS and
the ethics of harvesting we have two
different certification levels tier one
which is mushrooms that are easy to
identify there's no toxic GLC allyes and
they're not likely to cause in illness
in humans the idea is that's for the
person who's more of a casual person who
might only do a small amount then a tier
two list that includes a lot of other
mushrooms which can be more difficult to
identify may have toxic gcco lies or may
make a small percentage of humans ill
when a food establishment or a private
purchaser purchase they have to purchase
from a certified Harvester or from a
distributor that is consistent with the
level of certification for that
mushroom now the registration program
would also be in the Department of
Health and Human Services and there'll
be an online database updated as new
individual certify a certification card
given to each certified Harvester and
identifier and distributor as well
likewise public notification would be
given to the uh restaurant suppliers
grocery stores Farm stands farmers
markets so that they know that only
certified wild mushroom Harvesters Andor
Distributors would be allowed to sell
wild H harvested mushrooms as food the
point is the way that the wording goes
in the food code is that any other
source would not be considered an
approved source and therefore would not
be allowed to be used they would also be
informed as to what mushrooms are in the
list by just having descriptions and
photographs if they wish to look at that
the goal is to have the safety because
the certified uh um licensed forager
would know what they're doing but if
they want to check it they can take a
look at that information too and then
DHHS would have the responsibility for
inspecting wild harvested mushrooms and
Grocery Stores um they are already have
that capability and are the ones who
would uh already be pulling the license
or cease and assist orders with people
who were selling them currently because
again it cannot be done currently and
they'd have the authority to Levy fines
for
non-compliance um in order to be able to
track the mushrooms in case there is a
problem the Harvester or distributor uh
generates a labeling tag that goes on
the mushrooms allows tracking now it's
important to realize that most of the
work on this program has already been
done in the mushroom foraging commission
we had two mycologists on the team we
had we went over the uh the tier one and
tier two lists and compiled those uh Dr
Rick vapo who's going to be testifying a
little later on uh has already has a
framework for a course that's completed
there's a course at UNH uh some of the
states just actually use courses by
their micology organizations in the
state so the point is that the idea is
that the state doesn't have to generate
a course they just approve it now with
regard to the amendment just last week
representative fellows who was one of
the co sponsors was contacted by a
person who questioned whether this bill
would apply to the harvesting of chaga
mushrooms now chaga mushrooms are not
what we normally think of as a mushroom
because a mushroom is the fruiting body
of a fungus the chaga is not the
fruiting body it is the Mycelia of the
fungus that is harvested dried and
ground to make tea purported to be
medicinal we don't normally think of
chaga is a an edible mushroom but to
clarify this uh we went ahead to put in
an amendment that would Define the uh a
mushroom as the fruiting body of a
fungus that would therefore exempt chaga
I would look forward to um the Dr Vandal
to comment whether he thinks we really
need this amendment and likewise we do
have uh lined up to testify um Eric
Milligan who owns the New Hampshire
mushroom company that grows mushrooms
and he also uh is a collector of wild
mushrooms and would like to be able to
get back to
and also uh Colleen Smith from the food
protection of DHHS is here to talk to us
today too um so that's basically the
nuts and bolts of it and I'm open for
any representative Roy H thank you for
taking my question um is this Federal
Regulation how how long has this been an
effect and um
are there currently any wild harvested
mushrooms being sold right now in the
hampire in answer to the first question
it is the 2017 US Food Code although
that that is the date that is used I
don't know exactly when it was adopted
in New Hampshire uh Cony Smith will be
able to answer that because that is her
field um as far as whether some of them
are sold now um I'm sure that some may
be sold but that that would be at this
point illegal uh it's not an approved
food source um and
actually ER Eric Milligan who will be
discussing things later helped me a
little bit with this bill back when it
first came up uh way back before we
developed the commission because he's
had experience of people coming in
trying to sell him mushrooms where three
out of three were not what they were
claiming they were and so it certainly
is something that does go on and is can
you okay
other
questions seeing none I haven't received
so Smith yes Miss Smith if you would
care to speak
up thank you madam chair and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Colleen Smith I am the administrator of
the food protection section within the
Department of Health and Human Services
and I'm here to speak in support of Bill
345 that establishment establishes a
licensing program for mus mushroom
Harvesters um as representative kerk
mentioned the wild mushroom foraging
study commission I previously served on
that commission work closely with
representative kerk and members of that
commission to um Forge a pathway forward
for the legal sale of wild mushrooms at
our licensed food establishments um as
representative kerk mentioned we have a
adopted the 2017 US Food and Drug
Administration food code into our
administrative rules that adoption
happened um in two thou 2019 in August
2019 So within the food code it allows
uh state to develop a the its own
program for the saf Harvest and and sale
to food
establishments uh we would be also happy
if asked to provide a fiscal note as
there is
language within the legislation for the
Department to collect a a fee and to
administer fines for non-compliance with
u with the
regulation and I'd be happy to answer
any questions that you may have with
with regard to uh the Department's role
in this Bill yes I have a question about
the uh the license fees
what what did you estimate to be the
approximate type of p and do you have an
idea of how many people will be
interested so uh the statute sets a
$75 would set a $75 registration fee
which would be for a fiveyear
registration at this time we we don't
have um a clear estimate of how many
Harvesters we would have in um in the
year I think we had thought potentially
maybe 50 um in our in our work with the
commission thank
questions right seeing none thank you
very much
Mr Mr
vandero yeah hi uh thank you uh chair
person Maguire uh for this opportunity
to speak at the hearing for House Bill
I am in support of this bill as I've
indicated uh online and have worked
closely with representative kerk and
Colleen Smith representative fellows and
other members of the mushroom foraging
Commission in
2018 um we addressed quite a few
different parameters relative to this
licensing uh requirement that we're
proposing and I believe we work through
most most of the uh
issues that seem to be at the table it
took quite a bit of time but I encourage
you to read the minutes of these
meetings if you have specific questions
and have concerns about various
stakeholders in this process um I myself
am a myologist I have a graduate degree
in myology I've taught myology at The
Graduate and undergraduate level uh both
in this state and out of this state um
and I currently serve as the president
of of the northeastern mological
Federation um I have been involved with
mushroom collecting harvesting selling
trading uh since
1977 and uh I look forward to having
something on the books that replicates
what we have for other licensed
professions I'm a certified Wetland
scientist I served on the New Hampshire
joint board for 10 years as the
chairperson I wrote the exam for wetland
science field the field portion uh and
assisted in the written test for wetland
scientists I also helped write the exam
for the soil scientist so I'm familiar
with how to write certification exams
that provide some shity for the public
that a person is qualified to do the job
they're tasked to do and uh I also on
the commission related a couple of other
stories uh relative to the problems we
currently face uh relative to selling
Wild harvested mushrooms uh for sale in
unlicensed organizations and food food
clubs and I have several times come
across uh what I would consider toxic
mushrooms ones that weren't necessarily
fatally poisonous but ones that could
certainly cause
hospitalization for sale on the shelves
at um farmers markets and actually in
grocery stores um I've every time I
found that I've pulled these mushrooms
off the shelf and talk to the produce
manager um it hasn't happened often and
I must uh state that over the past say
decade things have gotten better the
Harvesters are more Savvy they're more
trained but there are still issues that
we need to deal with relative to the
possible ill effects of toxic mushrooms
being sold in restaurants and to U other
food Outlets so I encourage the
committee to consider this bill uh uh
seriously to to pass it and to also
allow those of us that have been trained
in this field to uh do our jobs in
providing both Public Safety and an
excellent food source for the public and
with that I'd be happy to answer any
questions you may have thank
you
yes
yes are there any other questions from
the
thank you madam
chair uh Rick it's good to see you
again and the question I have is uh many
people are quite aware of the fact that
mushrooms are delicious commercial
mushrooms uh and some mushrooms are
famous French are famous for their
Truffles and so forth um but people are
generally are quite often know that you
don't want to get the B the worst a bad
mushroom or a poisonous mushroom
anywhere near you how much would the
would the uh Market expand if we had uh
you know a
rigorous collection and and distribution
Network that would enable people to be
sure that that that some exotic mushroom
uh that they had heard about was
actually the real thing and um and
they'd like to try it how much do you
think the market would expand if we had
the kind of rigorous uh uh licensing or
operation that this bill sets up in
place thanks very much for the question
Peter good to see you too um I have only
anecdotal reports of the increases and
sales for volumes of of wild harvested
mushrooms for states that have certified
wild mushrooms
Harvesters um Indiana is is a lead state
Rhode Island is another one North
Carolina we have several states that are
considering it or have accomplished it
but I unfortunately don't have any hard
data in terms of uh how that you know
affects the actual flow of mushrooms I
would state that since selling wild
Harvesters mushro harvested mushrooms at
this point in time in New Hampshire is
illegal that I can only imagine that
with a certification process and the
legality being taken care of that that
volume would increase um I would
encourage you perhaps to ask that same
question to Eric Milligan who I believe
will be testifying as well since he owns
the New Hampshire mushroom company
and yeah up in Tamworth exactly and he
he um will U have certainly some numbers
relative to how much uh his sales of
wild harvested mushrooms may be affected
in the future by this bill terrific
looking forward to it I enjoyed him the
last time he was
here I did want to just mention one
other thing if you if I could add
uh representative Maguire that is um I
believe representative kerk asked about
uh sentiments relative to chaga since
that's a highly valuable mushroom that's
been um sold now for many many years and
is um uh
certainly at at issue here because it is
not on the list and I have I believe
that that's probably a good thing uh
likely simply because it's U not a
mushroom itself it is in fact uh as
representative kerk said in a melium but
more specifically it's a canker and it
being a canker part of the purported
medicinal value of that canker lies in
the betulinic acid that comes from the
birch tree and since it is almost always
on a birch tree I would state that
harvesting it has a very different
ecological effect than harvesting a wild
mushroom is most of you probably know
you pick a mushroom out of the ground
it's like picking an apple off the tree
mushrooms are fruits they're meant to be
consumed and spread around that's why
they are attractive tasty fleshy and
provide food value for wildlife but but
caners are something different and they
don't necessarily have food value per se
but they have medicinal value and
therefore we believed at least many of
us on the commission that this was a
different organism that wasn't um you
know appropriately included in the tier
one or tier two list so I thought I just
i' mention those uh bits of fact and and
I again I'd be happy to answer further
questions from the committee yes thank
you representative fellows you cannot
ask questions you're co-sponsor of this
bill so I'm afraid you must remain
silent um I just want to clarify I
thought the rule was that if I testified
that I could not ask a question you are
a co-sponsor that correct that is not
correct rule is that if you are a for
the bill you cannot act as a member of
the committee for the purposes of the
area
so thank you for that
migan was I muted that whole time yes
you were sorry I'll start again my
name's is Eric Milligan I'm the primary
owner of New Hampshire mushroom company
in Tamworth New Hampshire uh we were
established in
2012 um I speak in support of HB
345 um it is one of the thing it's what
I do um to answer the question
specifically about the increase uh I
represent many foragers and uh
individuals that I've purchased
mushrooms from in the past I want to be
able to be allowed to legally
forage market and sell wild mushrooms
um because that in what this program is
doing is is putting the into place an
approved Source uh myself being one of
those once I go through all of it um you
know the
process in regards to financial to
answer that question of coming in
um I've gotten reports from a couple of
foragers where you want to talk about
specifics you know almost a yearly wage
and for us here at the farm about uh you
know again depending on mother nature
income I yield the rest of my
time unless anyone's got any questions I
questions seeing none thank you very
much you still offering your T your
tours
Eric uh uh due to covid uh starting in
March of 2020 uh no one's been allowed
in the
building curbside pickup
only yeah Agri tourism was a bit of a
hit this year thank you Mr Milligan does
anyone else wish to testify on House
Bill
[Music]
did
hello yes ah thank you I uh was just
having a uh computer anxiety moment
there um yes thank you my name is Doug
ginsky I own White Mountain forager and
I'm neutral on this bill I'm kind of in
favor of the concept but I don't really
want to put myself out there is
endorsing every concept of this bill I
think the best thing to do is to tell
you a little bit of how my business came
to be um in 2013 I retired from a career
in fishing game as a conservation
officer and I served the last nine plus
years as the district Chief in Coos
County when I retired I had I'm blessed
to have a pension and I was looking for
something that would fill the Gap and
keep me
occupied at that time I was selling mush
Chantell mushroom to the balsams
restaurant which had a Culinary Kitchen
world class and I was selling several
thousand dollars of mushrooms a year so
when I retired I figured that would be a
great way to fill the Gap so I did my
research being a law enforcement
Prosecuting my own cases things of that
nature I looked for applicable laws and
I found
none in
2013 and I interpreted that as the fact
that mushrooms were an unregulated
industry because whether you acknowledge
it or not it is a very um active
industry in New Hampshire so unknowingly
I went ahead and filed an LLC White
Mountain forager um acknowledged wild
mushrooms is my business I got product
liability insurance and I went about my
business of um collecting and developing
markets for my mushrooms um I am was a
conservation officer I know landowner
ethics I comply with many of the
provisions with regards to acquiring
landowner per permission from um people
before I use their land and I go about
and I've been very successful and then I
sold mushrooms to the littleon food
co-op
chantells and one of your HHS food
inspectors lives in that area and we
graciously acknowledge that I couldn't
do that and it needed to be addressed
and needed to be fixed and I think
that's why we're here today um my
business has
been doing way better than I really wish
it would because I'm supposed to be
retired but what I guess what my point
is is that in seven years I now have a
half a dozen or so people that required
that I required w9s from for tax
purposes at the end of the year I have a
very active and growing business I find
that Supply is not the issue um so much
in that demand is so strong that I can
understand why there are food safety
requirements so I want this to be done
but I at the same point don't want to
stifle uh what we have as um going again
I've been in business for close to eight
years now um done quite a bit
of um business inside of New Hampshire
and outside and I have never had a claim
on my um liability insurance so I don't
I take offense to the term being used as
it's illegal because I believe at this
moment it's unregulated and I don't want
to get into uh into you know definitions
of words however I went into this with
Noble intentions and I don't like being
tagged as a poacher because I'm doing
something that I did since I was knee
high to my grandmother and I'll yield my
time thank you very much Mr brinsky are
you is there anyone else who wishes to
testify five representative fellows I
believe this is a good time for you
thank you madam chair um I served this
is representative fellows I served on
the um mushroom commission and I just
wanted to clarify that um while the
commission um discussed which mushrooms
would go on tier one which are the ones
that are easiest to identify and um we
did come up with a list that that was
just to kind of con ceptual activity and
that the actual um responsibility for
developing that list will be under
Health and Human
Services thank you very much is there
any questions for representative
fellows seeing none is there anyone else
testify all right seeing none I will
close the public hearing on house bills
34 5 and open the hearing on House Bill
yella
what
can you hear me yes there you are
representative yella please introduce
and introduce the
Bill thank you uh Madame chairman and uh
members of the
committee my name is uh representative
Josh yella I am introducing
HB
219 um
regarding the repeal of the statute for
athlete agent RSA 332
J
I uh looked at this uh statute
specifically BEC and and the and the
bills to follow specifically because
they um require no training
and education
requirements and in my
research um for this this statute it
seems to be that um in normal situations
if you have someone representing someone
else uh the person that
they are representing is the person that
is actually held responsible for those
actions um you know if you if you are a
normal business owner and you employ
someone and you get in a car accident
while you're on the job the
responsibility often goes to the if
you're doing that action um like as a
representative of that business or of
that person then you are the the actual
person that is um um that you are
representing is held
responsible and uh the athlete agent
seems to be an unusual case and I
believe it to
be um an unusual case because of
Institutions like the
NCAA that
um
hold people
responsible or specifically colleges
responsible for actions
that uh may be done by the by an
agent while not technically under a
contract or anything with an agent with
a um a student such as buying them
dinner or giving them a gift etc etc if
the if
the college student accepts the gift
they may be doing something which opens
up colleges to
liability from the NCA um daa contract
that they have um the NCAA is private
and not a government um agency and
so that is a a contractual agreement
that those those colleges go into um
willingly and
uh so
it's I think that the um legislation is
actually trying to fix kind of uh an
issue that is uh created by some private
contracts and uh the NCA daa is is
changing their rules uh
regarding um who can and who cannot
uh essentially uh make money off of
their likeness etc etc you may have
heard of this um they were supposed to
come out with with uh some guidance um
in January regarding this but it
has been kind of uh stalled a little bit
so we expect that this these new rules
will be coming out in the new near
future and
uh there and so I think that the the
committee
um may want to uh hold off on deciding
this bill
until
those actions come come out and so
that's why I sent uh an amendment to you
guys earlier today offering
uh to change the bill to a study
committee to look into whether or not
first of all um whether or not athlete
agents are treated differently than
other representatives of
people um you know nowadays there
are options for people to be represented
um have contracts and become you know
YouTube stars or whatever at younger and
younger ages you know twitch streamers
making contracts with uh
companies um to sponsor them or um and
also these options for NCAA may open up
the possibility for high school students
you know um a wide range of people to be
represented in in a uh a lot of
different ways and so it's kind of
brings up the question on whether or not
um athlete agents should have their own
designation or if it if really what the
um the law is trying to do is to allow
some pass through some some um pass
through from the um a third party that
has a contract or is essentially held
responsible for the actions of a
person uh like the college have being
held responsible for the actions of a
student or the student's
agent um
whether that
be uh you know a brand manager or in
this case an athlete agent it's possible
that this needs to be completely
Rewritten and said you know allow for
that pass through or for
the um that we might decide that it's
not appropriate for that pass through to
happen and that the per that those
people are acting um under the dis the
guidance of the athlete or and that
those the athlete should be held
responsible and it's really a
contractual agreement between the
athlete and the school that needs to be
some there are some uh opportunities
for waiting I I expect by um by the time
that the a study committee would would
form that the uh ncaaa will have drafted
in uh its new
rules and so it's possible that you
would have more information about how
to uh address this or manipulate this uh
statute going
forward I'm happy I'm happy to answer
any questions you have thanks we are not
going to form a study committee this
year so would you prefer that we voted
to kill this bill or that we and you
come in with a revised bill that
addresses the issues you're concerned
with or do you want us to retain it to
year I will say that the issues you're
bringing up of liability and
representation are not the normal issues
we deal with in DNA so we will probably
not be very
helpful
um I think that it would be better to
just so I so you want
to the options you're suggesting are
itl
I
um I feel like that's up to the
committee I'm I'm willing to I'm willing
to work on the issue over the summer and
and come back to the committee okay with
with more information absolutely it's
not we will keep that in mind
representative
question um for exact okay fine there
yet other questions for representative
Yuka
all right representative Horan you wish
Bill yes I yes I I'd love to speak to it
um I muted my so now I'm unmuted so my
name is Timothy Horan I represent
straford County District Six which is
the towns of uh Durham and Madbury and
Durham not in coincidentally is a
college town which has an extensive and
University of Hampshire has an extensive
of a division one Athletics program and
I am a season ticket holder and a
supporter of those programs although I'm
just expressing my opinion so um I
haven't uh consulted with the uh you
know the athletic department or the
other parties that are deal with it so I
think this
bill um bills totally unnecessary um it
Ling is definitely the way to go with it
um when it gets to the floor I guess
repent yella could try to Cable it in
which case then he'd be free to
reintroduce it it next year but I I I
don't see much value in that so the um
he's talk about private contracts and
um I agree I don't disagree with all
that in principle but the fact is that
uh Sports both uh amateure Sports and
professional sports are very highly
regulated industry they're a uh um
mostly by so they have very uh very
elaborate rules for who's eligible and
who's not and so um one of the problems
is if you sign a contract with an agent
who then doesn't act your backed
interest you can lose your eligibility
um so that's uh and that happens that
happens to a student athletes all the
time um so they they're they're very you
know there's very strict rules what a
student athlete can do and can't do and
you know maybe that's maybe that's not
how it should be but that's the way it
is and um it's a positive experience I
know it's a positive experience for the
vast majority of the students at UNH and
Dartmouth and the other schools that
have programs so they consider very it's
a very positive it's considered very
positive by the vast majority of those
who participate in college athletics um
and also the other thing which I guess
Rend yella didn't bring up which I
thought he was going to is that uh you
might say well there aren't that many
professional athletes in New Hampshire
there's
um there's probably more than more than
you think um we have a uh um because
there are uh you know there are usually
un football team at Dartmouth
occasionally send a player to the pros
there's um nobody from UNH has ever
played professionally but there is a
player who grew up in Newcastle who's a
star in the NBA named Duncan Robinson so
this does affect some people and
also up also like before that um this
law also restricts this also um this Al
law also um deals with people who are uh
who are recruiters um often
unauthorized by the colleges but there's
often boosters and others you get hold
of the families and um you know and you
know play on their you know play on
their hopes for their for their child's
future as a professional or college
athlete and so some of those um some of
those can act in ways which can end up
uh you know costing the families you
know a large amount of money wasting a
lot of their time and also some cases uh
taking away The Young Person's uh uh
eligibility of playing college and also
don't thing about professional sports is
um in most countries our system of
College athletics doesn't exist so
there's usually uh a network of amateur
and Semi-Pro professional clubs and so a
lot of those um I know especially in uh
basketball which I'm the most personally
familiar with because um I've been
sitting in the stands for 15 years I've
gotten to know uh some of the people
affiliated with it especially a few
years ago it was a player whose father
was actually in the business of sports
and so a lot of these um so there are
like a lot of uh there are a lot of
Scouts who recruit players for uh you
know professional minor league
professional teams overseas especially
in basketball which has even though it's
invented here in the USA is just as
popular everywhere in the globe there's
probably thousands of professional teams
all of which have all of which like it
possible to get a couple of uh us
players in there just to because you
know
the players I think are better Coach
better coached in in many yeah so this
is yes anyway just the original Bill
anyway I'll get back to the original
bill passed um in 2006 it uh and um it
hasn't been changed since and nobody's
asked to get rid of it till now it is
obviously a target for people just
looking to you know eliminate quotequote
unnecessary regulation but I I don't
think this is I this regulations need
it's not onerous and also it's a
uniform bill so even in 2006 it was
existed in 40 other states and I think
it's probably more now I'm not aware of
any that have abolished it so this is a
this is a necessary bill it protects the
families and the student athletes and uh
and the institutions so I I think we
should leave we should leave this uh RSA
330 TJ in place it's worked well since
2006 and it should stay in place um so
that's uh that's why I think you should
you should itl this bill if um I mean
you are there any questions for
representative
Oregon Thank you very much M CH M CH I
say yeah I I agree there's no point
having a study commission um this bium
when things
are thank you we are not going to have a
study committee on
this okay seeing no other questions
thank you represent for are there any
other members of the public that wish to
219 seeing none I will close public
hearing
15 minutes have it do we wish to go into
executive session on this bill I'm TR
for that
okay you have a motion right uh my
motion is itl on uh House Bill 219
second by
Schmidt
okay okay do you wish to speak to your
motion um
I mean as Josh said it's really not the
time to be doing this because we don't
know what the new rules are and so
should I all this and if there's a need
to do something in the future a new bill
can be
introduced
ditto thank you represent sh for your
discussion all right in that case the
motion is inexpedient to legislate and
the clerk will call the role
representative
Roy
no the motion is inexpedient to
did I didn't hear the vote is that yes
or no yes it was a
no representative Roy voted no
representative scitec voted yes wait a
minute you voted no I voted against the
IDE
against the it I'm sorry
okay thank you for
clarifying okay uh the clerk what yes
representative
Pearson representative Pearson going
twice no vote from representative
Pearson uh Representative
yakovich no
no uh representative leus
yes representative algro
yes representative Bailey
here no
vote representative
Lara
sasto representative s taso going
twice no
vote representative
Coy
yes representative
sh
Judy
yes
yes representa Judy show us your face oh
I'm here one minute one minute one
here oh madame chair because the first
[Music]
excellent representative Schmidt yes
representative Schultz
yes representative
fellows
Le
yes representative
groa
chair
yes
votes I'd just like to say that I just
that I'm getting
something it seems like a delay on the a
yes before the words completely got out
of um representative citec mouth
so I think it's related to your to the
um big
room
possibly especially if we're all we're
all unmuted I think it
contributes yes what was the vote total
again please
thank you represent y yila did you wish
something
yeah it sounds as though the that if he
were to come back with a with a bill it
would be very different from this one so
could be introduced I would think so can
you hear me yes no I just I just wanted
I it looked like I was removed from
being an attendee or whatever and um I
have more bills like all the rest of the
bills are mine so I was just planning to
stay on okay we we will you in touch
this one I think needs
more more work
before is there any objection to consent
before we leave this this bill
no
okay this consent like I'll take a a
minutes
I will move ought to pass on House Bill
356 which is the technical changes to
the Manchester retirement
second and in response to that this is
something we passed last year it's an
efficiency Improvement for the system it
makes no changes to the benefits or the
relations with the employees it simply
allows the system to come into cont into
agreement with IRS rules and then to
replace a person who resigns or moved
out of the
district what's the bill number again
Madame chair
you
speak no thank
discussion seeing
none
um that case the motion is ought to pass
on House Bill
356 the
uh changes to the retirement system for
Manchester employees the
representative Roy yes clerk votes yes
representative
Pearson
yakovich
yes representative leus yes
representative Allegro
yes representative
Bailey not here uh repres representative
lanzara
naso
vote representative
goalie
yes representative
Judy
we you hear me we heard you we
you representative Schmid yes
representative
Schultz yes representative
fellows yes
representative
lebranch
O'Brien
V uh yes on O'Brien okay thank you
represent terrific uh representative
Maguire
I take it there's no objection to
consent we got that time to do that
other Manchester
bill I we have five minutes before the
can okay just checking with you Carol
256 which was a very straightforward
bill with no debate so I think we'll
we'll pause here for the next
hearing
logic Terry are you hearing
clear how long do we have
minute
so
[Music]
close thank you representative Schmid
bying
our
Madame chairman as long as we're in a a
lull I'll just check in with you to make
sure you saw the email from the State
Fire Marshal that came in late this
bill he is he is the only person signed
up to
speak um but he was not able to stay for
the afternoon he had a
awake so
he did subit written testimony however
and sent it to everybody at about 11:18
this
morning Pam are you talking about the
the one and only letter from the fire
marshal this
morning the only one I have
seen well I mean there was one there was
one that came in from the Fire Marshall
with regard to that bill and you're
that's what you're referring to
referring to absolutely the his it's a
fairly brief letter about the the
lightning rod right oh the lightning rod
oh I didn't see anything about the
lightning rod Bill did you forward that
to us yeah it was sent to you he he sent
it to everybody okay I I'll look for
yet
minutes
LIC
right being two
o'clock open the hearing on House Bill
jila thank you Madame chairman and uh
members of the
committee uh for the record my name
again is representative joshu Kella um I
am
representative from
Fremont and I am
introducing
HB
208 right
regarding
uh the lightning rod dealer salesman
licensing and the repeal of that uh
lure statute um I looked up on
the uh New Hampshire Department of
Safety
Administration uh website it doesn't
look like it's been updated
since maybe 2017
2018 um back then there were only four
dealers active in the state um once
again
there's uh no
uh education or training requirements
obviously they would need
to um you know anyone installing testing
modifying or repairing lightning
products uh would need to
follow requirements
of the
NFPA um
780 standards and uh that's essentially
all that one needs to do to to uh do
this job and so um I don't believe that
lure is required I believe
that um this could be repealed and if if
the um committee believes that we we
could adopt you know uh something saying
that all persons have to follow this
um protection that's that seems fine but
I think it would be covered through the
process at local
uh at local uh planning and
zoning and so I don't believe this needs
to be a a state state license
so with that I will take any
questions thank you did you read the
letter from the Fire
Marshall I don't believe I received a
letter from the Fire Marshall oh well in
that case I'll paraphrase he says that
it's was created in
1878 and the requirements for lightning
rods are included in the state fire code
and the state electrical code and this
is no longer needed he supports the
repeal okay well I agree with him then
is
question does anyone else wish to
hearing
yeah I'll make a motion okay
representative leas
moves I'd like to make a motion um ought
to pass on house bille 208 I'll second
Pearson do you wish to speak to your
motion um as the state for mercial said
um the license isn't needed um you know
this is all covered by existing state
fire code electrical code and their
existing standards so there's no need
for
this Pearson do you wish to speak to
your
second I think representative leus did
an eloquent and outstanding job his
explanation excellent does anyone else
speak see none in that case the motion
is ought to pass and the call the
role
yes books yes representative
Pearson yes representative
yakovich yes representative leus yes
representative algro yes representative
Bailey is not
voting uh representative
lanzara yes
naso not voting representative
goalie
yes representative
sh
yes representative Judy
we we trust the video
please mam chair
we
representative
yes representative
SCH
yes
representative um I I think I heard my
name called yes do you he
yes
yes yes yes yes wonderful uh represent
have a connection issue I'll yell out
the
window representative
lebranch
yes representative groa
yes representative
O'Brien
yes and the chair
yes um
17 Z excellent any objections to
consider
bit
seven we have eight minutes if there's
another easy Bill we might get to it
does anyone have a motion on on
effort W did we have to vote on
Hansville
425 we have not yet you wish make a
motion I'll make a motion
OTP on House Bill
425 isn't there an amendment on that
um
said the the it
positions yes sorry there was an
amendment presented at the hearing I
understand yes I'm sorry I make a motion
on Amendment for House Bill 425 the
d278 okay
excellent is there a second move second
second on the amendment by
Schmidt thank you repeat the number
please 27 27 okay
2127 all right do you wish to speak to
your motion representative
groda
no uh well but this was done at the
request of the Department of Information
Technology and it removed and the
amendment removes was already in the RSA
sections one and two and uh that and
already
did does anyone else wish to
425 well it's the amendment on yes the
amendment on house 425 all right the
motion is ought to pass on Amendment
27h and the CLE call the rooll one
ready on the amendment uh representative
Roy yes repes the clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative
yakovich yes representative leus yes
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey still not present
representative
lonara
yes Representative
saso
no representative
goalie
yes representative
Judy there he is representative Schmid
smiling face at all
yes representative
Schulz
fellows yes representative
labranch yes representative groda yes
representative
O'Brien
yes and the chair yes okay
170 two two not present all right we we
voted the the amendment representa you
have a
motion yes Madam chair I'd like to move
um a to pass as amended on House Bill
FN is there a
second I'll
second I'll second oh sorry Diane be
Diane beat me to it yes indeed do you
motion this bill um um current this bill
verifies and confirms what's being done
already but um by the O Department of
Information Technology and it is
important
criteria of for the safety of the state
thank you representative Shu do you wish
to speak to or your second I just uh
ditto all right is anyone else wish to
speak on Amen on House Bill 425 I do
representative citech I want to know who
moved the
amendment
and okay I seconded I seconded the
amendment I'm finished talking very good
anyone else wish to
speak
okay in that case the motion is ought to
pass with amendment by representative
Roa and when ready the will
follow representative
Roy BL votes yes representative Pearson
yes representative
representative was that representative
algro yes okay not sure what I heard
there representative Bailey just in case
representative
lazara yes so easy
Santo representa goalie yes
representative sh yes representative
Judy
we representative Schmidt yes
representative
Schultz yes representative
fellows yes representative
please sugar on topa
oan yes and the chair yes a familiar
170 does anyone object to
consent that a
chance okay we'll put that one on
consent
also
Monday which are
those which are the early ones from the
okay in that case I'm going to open the
hearing on House Bill 218 and call
sponsor thank you madam chairman and uh
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is representative Josh
Oella I
am representative for Fremont uh
introducing HB
218 uh relative to uh the repeal of this
the requirement
for itinerant vendors to
be uh licensed in the state um
this is a statute that applies to PE to
businesses that come to our state and uh
to engage in a
temporary uh
business but they have an actual
business in uh other another
state and I believe that
a lot this this uh requirement also
requires that they
have
uh
bond with the state and I think that it
is not it is they they shall it says
that they shall make a special deposit
of
$5,000 um in the F form of cash or
security bond with the secretary of
state and I think that this law is you
know uh a very old law and I think that
it is
not um commensurate with the times of um
a lot of a lot of
uh selling interstate is now happening
on the internet and I think it's
partially from uh rules like this that
limit people from from uh just coming in
for a short time you know the extra
hurdles of of putting this as an
impediment to to
uh that that the online option doesn't
doesn't require you know whether it be
uh selling through through their website
or
um other such means um you know putting
it through Amazon or whatever if they
want to sell their their products and so
I think it actually is a detriment to
the state and I think we need to
consider uh a repeat of this the statute
when there are other options and it
seems to be that we are um putting
people that want to actually come to the
state and uh do business here
at uh disadvantage and encouraging them
to to make those sales online so I thank
you and I'd uh welcome any
questions
question yes thank you reprid blus was
first um okay is it my understanding
correct that this bill will leave in
place the existing RSA
3112a which permits uh you know local
towns to regulate itinerant vendors so
if they think they have a particular
locally yes it doesn't it does not
affect that okay thank you
representative Schmidt thank you madam
chair so representative did you inquire
of the Secretary of State's office
whether there's this bill is actually or
this statute is actually in in use you
cited modern technology and so forth I
think the the bill is intended to
protect the public from people who come
in and sell whatever that or service or
good product or whatever that maybe is
fraudulent and so forth so the the bond
is probably to protect the citizenry and
the towns not to facilitate the trade
I'm wondering whether you've checked
with the SEC Secretary of State's office
since represent since David scanland is
here I'd like to find out if you haven't
talked with him what he has to say about
age I think that that um so I just
looked on to the on the uh website
for I did not rec I did not uh talk to
them directly so I think he would be
best to answer that
question thank
you representative
Shu thank you madam chair um having
served on Municipal and County
government many years ago we heard uh
about a similar bill and I believe that
this statute covers
um I say small rather independent say
magazine salesmen or people who sell
Goods going door Todo uh quite often the
towns that they are operating in are not
even aware of their presence uh if they
do not go through the actual licensing
uh
process and therefore unless they get a
complaint from one of their
citizens uh there's not going to be
local consent
implied um unless there's a problem and
at that point I fear that it would be
too late uh unless there is some kind of
Licensing already put in place that they
could show a potential customer customer
recourse
is representative Shu
that yes I I'm sorry I tried to say at
the end would you agree that that is the
type of person that's covered by
this thank you so I think that um what
you're probably referring to is more
covered by the um definition of Hawker
and
peder um which is the bill that we're
going to be hearing next but
um it depends where I guess the business
is located um if it's an out of-state
business that it would be an itinerant
vendor if it's like an instate business
then it would be a hawk or a
peder um but I think that uh in my
experience um people do people generally
you know with the first knock on the
door they are going on Facebook and
asking who you know who this person is
does anyone know them have have they
bought um anything from them etc etc and
so at least in my experience the word
travels extremely fast and people know
exactly who it is and um there is a lot
of commentary on whether or not you
should trust them or if you'd use their
service before and if they're reliable
etc etc um I definitely have experienced
that um you know within minutes of
people uh that do come door Todo but
none of them ever mentioned that they go
to the state to find out that
information it's mostly um other people
uh discussing the service that is
offered
um on and whether it's good or not they
don't generally don't go to the state
for that
information followup Madam chair
followup thank you um are you aware
representative that a lot of older
senior
citizens uh who how shall I say an
unscrupulous itinerant vendor might prey
on uh do not have computers or do not
even think to go to Facebook or the
internet to look up um the identity of
door
um thank you for the question
I
do think that um I don't think that it's
uh specific
to um people of a certain age I believe
and I think that I was actually a victim
of someone that uh came to my door
talked on it and was selling um you know
news uh supposedly selling um magazines
for that were going to be donated to
Veterans and um you know if I gave them
this check then uh some veterans would
be receiving uh
magazines
and um only later like after the person
left
I mean I was suspicious the whole time
but I I think that uh only later after I
left did I um do more research on them
and find out that I think that it was a
scam um because uh
but and uh I I don't know that there
was I didn't do anything about it I just
I I decided whether or not I was going
to stop payment on the check and then
that was the end of that uh situation um
but
um I I don't
necessarily think that the the risk is
more from p a person knocking on the
door versus all of the scammers on the
internet trying to have you buy all
kinds of things
um I think actually being able to buy um
yeah so so I don't necessarily think
that that the risk is more in one place
versus another or one population versus
another I think um there are just
scammers out there and anyone can fall
prey so thank you for the
O'Brien thank you to the chair and thank
you sir for taking my question uh is it
your interpretation of this bill would
limit the governing board of any City
town or Village District to issue uh a
vendor license Haus pedalist and all
that uh to Food Services
providers and if that is the case they
have to get approval like in the example
in Nash through the Board of Health they
are open for inspection uh to make sure
that they are meeting the quality and
clean uh food standards that the uh the
public would uh
would expect second too uh does this by
eliminating this bill eliminate the
chance for in the example a ntion or any
other community on a farmer's market
limit uh gives them the chance to limit
the size of how bigger the farmer market
that they want and just kind of opens up
the door to any type of vendor that may
want to come in and sell his particular
product without regulation thank
you
sen Caleb yes I'm thank you for the
question um there seem to be a lot of
questions in that question but I don't
um I don't necessarily agree that this
will limit the powers of the
town this would be um whether or not
they had to go to the state first if
they if the
local
um municipality has regulations about
food vendors etc etc I think those would
still
apply uh followup if I may follow uh
thank you well I'm having a hard time so
I'm looking for some clarity if you
could please in my reading of this this
is enabling legislation to to allow the
governing board of a city town a village
District in order to take that Authority
by eliminating this it would remove that
authority to the local
jurisdiction excuse me representative
O'Brian yes mad chair RSA
3112a already exists okay thank you
clarifies that the towns and cities have
that authority to license these vendors
and simply as representative yila said
simply eliminates the requirement that
they go to the state first they the
authority to license them and they still
have the same authority to require the
same background checks or whatever it is
they they do do now and I thank the
fellows
question when I looked at the um two
bills I they I got them confused in my
mind but now that I look at the at the
um definition of itinerant vendors I see
it talks about somebody doing business
in a temporary place like a like a hotel
or a motel or vacant lot that that sort
of thing so so my question is how do you
think this would impact um and it
requires State Licensing it's it's not
about um the local license how do you
think it would impact businesses like
like the um motorcycle week where lots
of people put up tents and and they have
um different businesses and and you
could also have some place that sets up
a tent beside a motel and for most of
the summer sells some sort of goods but
they're not registered with the state
they you know you if if there's a
problem with the product you won't even
know who they were anymore so I
understand the other bill but this one
concerns thank you for the question um
representative
I don't have have those same concerns
the itiner vendor is is yes it could be
um could be could allow people from out
of state to set up a a
temporary um situation where they are
able to sell let's say like a um if a if
a business or or like your for example
where you have like a bike week or
something like that where businesses
want to um you know rent out space or
something like that in their parking lot
and say okay these businesses can come
and you know for a short short amount of
time say you know how great this new
bike is and they're an outof State
company and they just want to come in
for a short time to be able to display
their products on that um in front of
that business or motel or I mean
whichever business they want to you know
um I think that that would be at the
discretion of the owners of the property
of who they want to uh uh let on their
property and also it would be part of
the plan set out by the town and what um
is allowed in that specific area if if
other businesses are allowed you know if
if you have to get a a permit MIT um etc
etc so there would be still local
regulations regarding that and um I
think it's possible that the change
might be that there will be more
opportunity for outof State people to
events well thank you thank you repres
valro thank you for taking my question
most but not all of the discussion and
concern seems to be centered around um
the worst case scenario the
scammers um but I wonder how um
important that is in considering this
bill uh I so I I'll ask the question
would we expect
scammers uh to apply for lure with the
state so it still originates
complaint thank you for the question I I
don't necessarily believe that that all
of the um I definitely don't think that
the scammers especially the one that
came to my door was registered with the
state um it would have been pretty much
impossible to track him down because it
was just some random person um but and
so I think that this is just a hurdle
definitely for uh law abiding people to
um you know have to put up uh a bond and
uh fees and stuff like that and out
forms at the state level and then
potentially at the local level as well
thank you for clarifying
that representative
Shan thank you madam chair um more
questions have entered my mind going to
the question of local
control um first question if um as
representative O'Brien suggested some of
these folks and I I don't think we're
terribly concerned about large
corporations who uh bring their business
say to bike week I think they're
responsible but we're talking about the
smaller scale uh people who sell food
from a tent uh people who sell leather
goods just from a a tent that kind of
thing um and would it not be requiring
each town that they go to um report have
their business in
uh temporarily wouldn't it require that
town to have someone knowledgeable about
each of those different fields which
have thank you for the
question um so I think that there
are all types of businesses that may
come into a town and the
regulations for those are
relatively generic as to not
disenfranchise one versus another and I
think that there may be
concerns
uh that are normal in the in the process
of allowing a use of some property but I
definitely don't think that we want to
disenfranchise the small
businesses um
and and by by having this because it's
definitely going to be much harder for
small businesses to make dep deposits or
security bonds um available to the to
the state whereas obviously large
corporations would have no issue doing
that so I think that this is definitely
um has has more effect on the small
business uh aspect and definitely ones
that have um or are benefited by
physical presences instead of uh remote
presences like being
online further
question
followup thank you um my my other
thought is that most of these uh folks
who come and do business like this in
small towns tend to go through several
towns within a few days that would
require them to go to each individual
town to get a license rather than
getting one ticket so to speak from the
state uh you don't see that as an
additional hardship on the uh small
businesses that you're claiming this is
benefiting actually representative Shu
they're required to
to right now they are required to go to
every town that requires such a license
if that they do business in that's
current law this bill would not affect
goalie thank you madam chair I just want
to follow up uh I guess in the line of
Representative shu's questions because
as I look at the
definition um and it was stated earlier
principal place of businesses not in the
state who engaged in temporary or
transient business in the state either
in one locality or traveling from place
to place selling good wears
merchandise and then it goes on to uh
State also uh temporary place of
business means any public or quasi
public place including but not limited
to a hotel motel rooming house store
room building part of a building tent
vacant lot railroad car or
trailer um that's pretty mobile
and as it you further go out the state
representative yella uh I just and I'm
getting to my
question
Association provisions of this chapter
by reason of associating himself
temporar temporarily with any local
dealer Trader or Merchant or by
conducting such temporary transient
business in connection with or as part
of the business or in the name of any
local dealer Trader or Merchant that the
uh
vendor may this he may not associate
with I'm sorry on that one so my
question goes to you uh following up on
representative shuart don't you believe
it would be better for the state to keep
track of these vendors coming in and out
of the state having them on record so
cities and towns can look it up and make
sure they are a uh pertinent dealer and
uh have been vest vetted because if
they're Transit they're going to be
busing from town to town to town to town
and uh it's going to be up to localities
to review this individual uh upon
applying for the license versus being
able to just go to One location the
state for that vendor do you believe uh
it would be easier uh to keep this law
reason thank you for the question I
don't necessarily think it would be
easier to keep the law in place I mean
it's definitely easy to keep the law in
place we wouldn't have to do anything
but I think that um there so this what
you were just reading was um it says um
the local Association it says no
itinerant vendor shall be exempt from
these
Provisions just by reason of associating
themselves with any local dealer so if a
car dealership wants to host the company
that manufactures the the cars that they
produce and says hey these this is the
manufacturer they have this special um
deal going on with these cars or this
manufacturer that we don't normally have
at our dealership you know they are
selling their their wees here they would
need to go to the
state and file that uh information with
the state and the question of whether or
not the
local uh the the local municipality
wants to also
control that information uh or that
license is up to the local town if they
want to do that or not I don't think
that it's necessarily um helps them uh
to have an additional layer of
Regulation
chair so in reading the definition and
being a transient
group don't you would you agree that it
would be harder to keep track of these
individuals as they moved from town to
town if they were doing bad business in
the town and were kicked out or license
revoked um and moved on to the next town
by the time the next town was able to
research them before they gave out a
license versus just going to the state's
database um that it be easier for these
radar thank you for the for the followup
I I think that
the that
it that the damages any damages or
um can still be um
addressed by the company that where it
com is uh permanently based so this
would just be essentially like you know
a
popup uh let's say a popup McDonald's or
something like that for you know a few
days in this specific spot and or you
know it's May maybe McDonald's is not a
good example because they're in all 50
states but a a a business a restaurant
that doesn't normally is not normally in
New Hampshire comes to New Hampshire for
a popup restaurant gets their you know
food license stuff like that and then
um doesn't perform in in a way that that
is uh commensurate with that license I
do think that you know if there was
anyone harmed or anything like that I
think there still would be the the
company at its base location that could
be gone after after by the the people
that were affected I don't necessarily
think that the the fact that they
traveled necessarily would make it um
impossible for for that to be followed
up
on thank
BR thank you madam chair representative
yaka yella sorry if um
the let's say that this bill
passes and then it it up to the
um municipality
to monitor this and something
happens whose responsibility is it
within the municipality to notify other
municipalities let's say it's summer and
you know in our town on the coast
there's many
people so somebody starts in Hampton and
makes their way up to Portsmouth whose
responsibility is it in the
town to notify other towns and what's
that thank you for the question
um
my response is that I don't believe that
it is required that a town notify other
towns or States just like it's you know
not required that New Hampshire
notify
Florida if someone has an
issue uh in New Hampshire it would be
exactly the same situation you
wouldn't be required to notify other
municipalities States uh you would
uh the person that would be harmed could
go
to directly to that that company however
the municipality doesn't have
necessarily will have even jurisdiction
over over the actual fine depending on
whether or not
uh they have jurisdiction with with the
company as a
whole
chair
follow so that's what you think and what
basis is that thought what's the basis
of that thought that no one's
damaged relevant
question he says he doesn't know and
that's it
scanland thank you madam chair and
members of the committee I'm David
scanland deputy secretary of state and I
just wanted to provide the committee
with some
information uh the Secretary of State's
office is charged with the
administration of the statutes related
to itinerate vendors uh and Hawkers and
pedlers and what I can tell you uh with
that statute is that in terms of
itinerate vendors we probably receive uh
uh about 100 applications a year and
issu permits to those uh uh applicants
uh the number of Hawkers and pedlers
that we deal with are probably triple
that amount in the course of a year we
probably collect $220,000 in fees uh
that are paid by both itinerant vendors
and Hawkers and
peders and once the permit is issued
that is usually the last time we see
that individual until it's time to renew
the permit we received very few
complaints at the state level related to
these
individuals I can't recall ever having
to tap into the $5,000 shity bond that
uh you know that they uh put out there
when they apply and
um uh you know from from our perspective
it's you know it's pretty smooth sailing
with them now municipalities as as was
mentioned uh can issue their own permits
uh and I think most of the larger
communities do do that uh they may have
more uh interaction with these
individuals and it's possible that uh
you know they may do some some
enforcement uh at that level that that
we just don't
see the secretary of state is authorized
to revoke a license uh after a hearing
um I can't recall that uh ever having
taken place uh in recent memory either
um So based on that I mean we we don't
have strong feelings on this piece of
legislation one way or the other um if
it makes our you know our State
Community feel better because these
individuals have to register uh we're
certainly happy to continue to do that
uh but our experience has been that
there are very few issues with these
individuals at least at the state level
with that I'd be happy to answer any
questions representative Roy thank you
for taking my question Mr um can you
tell us what is involved in the process
of Licensing these folks do you do like
a criminal background check on them or
what what is involved in that it's a
very simple process the applicant comes
in in they fill out an
application uh one of the one of the
questions asked about any type of a
criminal record um and they answer the
question but there is no background
check beyond that uh even if they say
they have a a criminal record uh the
permit is still issued to them the fee
is
$50 follow up followup so just for
clarification the sole role of of the
office is to collect the fee and the
bond to ensure the bond and issue the
permit so there's there's really no um
necessarily benefit to the communities
other than knowing that that bond has
been isue is that a fair
statement that's fair I mean our our
role is
ministerial uh we keep a record of all
of those that receive a permit and as I
mentioned there is a provision that
allows the Secretary of State to revoke
a permit uh after a hearing but uh I
can't ever recall that being that part
you other
questions represent
fellows thank you madam chair um my
question um is just if the if Mr
scanland recalls any cases of people
being prosecuted because they were
license I can't recall that happening
either um I I would uh like to check
with the staff in our office just to see
if they're aware of anything like that
and I'll be happy to do that and get
back to the
committee thank
you representative
sh thank you madam chair good afternoon
Mr scandin good
afternoon
um would you say that the majority of
that you issue uh as the sponsor
suggests are issued through companies
that are doing business out of the state
and are just here temporarily or are
individual represent Shu I don't have a
an answer to that question off the top
of my head without researching that a
little bit and I'll be happy to do that
thank
goie thank you madam chair and David
welcome and thank you for taking the
question isn't this somewhat of a
deterrent to Bad actors looking to come
into the state um and it also gives some
accountability for cities and towns to
look back and see that they've uh put
the bond up and
uh have filled out the proper pap
paperwork as to their um legal
background whether they've been in
trouble or not and $50 is a small price
to pay to have
that um information
[Music]
available it it may be represent goalie
um it's it's one of those things where
from our perspective we just don't see a
history of um abuse of the permit but
that's not to say that just the fact
that we issue them isn't a deterrent to
uh
misbehavior and if it gives Comfort to
the uh citizens of the State of New
Hampshire then you know that may be
justification to maintain the law as it
is thank
questions seeing none thank you Mr
scandin thank you don't go away because
I'm sure we'll have similar ones on the
next
F does anyone else wish to testify on
218 all right seeing none I will close
the hearing open the hearing on House
yila thank you madam chairman and uh
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Josh uh representative
Josh
yella uh from
Fremont introducing uh HB
2117 uh repealing RSA 320 regarding
Hawkers and
pedlers uh much
of uh my comments on this would be
essentially the same as the the previous
Bill
and uh other than uh the fact that that
these are more likely to be
um people
that instead of
being uh serviced by potentially uh
Amazon or whatever uh would be much more
likely to be serviced by you know
Craigslist or or still eBay but also
we're comp we're competing with that and
um I think that it still allows for
these to be
uh regulated at the local level and so I
think that the
additional requirement for the state
level
uh license is not necessary and I would
consider consider that uh or I would
like the committee to consider uh
repealing this and supporting HB 217
thank you and uh I'll take any questions
thank you I have a question I looked at
2117 and
218 and it appears that if we passed
both of them the effect would depend on
which one was last because they do not
appear to be
please thank you for the question
um
that
is not my
intent and
uh I am not aware of that issue but I'm
happy to look into it and get back to
you well if you just look at the bottom
line uh line
14 House Bill 217 repeals deletes the
comment about RSA
320 and leaves
321 28 deletes 321 and leaves
so
coordinated right does anyone else have
a
none no one else has spoke has signed up
to
speak does anyone wish to testify on
217 okay then
hearing and we we will resume the public
build
377 377
377 A Fire Marshall and um Recovery
you so ah yes Miss
Vach
I raised my hand because I thought we
questions okay thank you do you have a
questions is this on House Bill this is
on the on the U recovery houses
correct black has a question I'm uh it
might have been the lady was just
speaking um um it was stated that uh the
fire State Fire Marshal Fire Marshals
can already Grant
exceptions for Recovery houses so this
bill isn't needed my question is are
they actually being granted are there
places trying to get exceptions where
um my understanding from um fire marshal
perzi was that he granted an exception
just a week or so ago but I see that
he's come on so maybe he's better to
represented mam chair I'm sorry did was
the question are we um granting
variances now is that what the question
was
yes thank you for the question uh the
answer is yes we have
granted
uh two or three
variances recently we've also
denied uh several but the denials to the
best of my recollection the denials
were at least a couple of years
ago thank you followup so given that you
can do that um you know what benefit do
you see if this law were
pass thank you for the question I think
it's a it's a it's something
that it's a fundamental uh policy
question that I think um Kim is
absolutely right Miss Bach is absolutely
right currently um we can issue a
variance to the state fire code under um
under the statute under under 153 and
under uh safe C
6000 however I I guess I look at this
more of a kind of a blanket policy
decision kind of like when the
legislature decided that we didn't want
to have uh sprinkle systems in one and
two family dwellings so rather than the
State Fire Marshals office take on the
full um responsibility of deciding
whether or not they're in a in a kind of
a global way whether uh recovery
residences ought to be exempt from
sprinklers um if they are if they were
to follow some other certain rules um we
feel as if it's it's best that this be
decided at a at a state
level so that everybody knows what the
rules are and so that if you're in
Pittsburgh or if you're in pelum you
know that this is available to you um as
opposed to um the possibility of
somebody uh doing a nimi game or or
somebody not highlighting this option to
a recovery
residence thank you welcome are there
other
questions
yes
representa thank you madam chair um I'm
asking this is a question for um Miss
Bach you represent a certain group of
recovery homes
correct
may I I I have a few questions may I ask
a followup
followup and that's only within a
certain region and there are many more
recovery houses that do not that are not
correct I'm sorry we
can't we we certify and our our
delegated to ser certify voluntarily
certify recovery houses across the state
of New
Hampshire it's up to the recovery house
to come to us to request
certification and um we have certified
so far 48 houses and we're working on
another seven or eight right now we know
of another about 30 that we're ready to
make contact with to see if they're
interested um but no there's no reason
for a recovery residents to become s
certified or to go on the state
required and followup
please um you mentioned that maybe a
Miss did you but you mentioned
that you were under tighter regulations
than other groups is that correct and
why if these exemptions
exist if I understand the question
correctly um if House Bill
passes New Hampshire cert core certified
houses or houses on the New Hampshire
state Registry of recovery
houses would be under stricter
regulations than those that receive an
exemption um they would be required to
have a walkth through from the um an
inspection from the fire department on
at least an annual basis um and there
were other pieces of that
bill that wouldn't be applied to
other congregate living situations in
the same
neighborhoods who were granted an
exemption there's a that laundry list of
items is all additional
things this is my last question I
promise thank you why can't
well I believe the short answer is they
can but they haven't yet okay thank
question yes I do Madam
chair so uh Miss uh Bach my question
goes to a statement you made earlier
before we recessed the hearing um it
seems to me like you're doing extremely
meticulous and solid laudable work I
don't have any issue with the issue
you're raising the question I have is
the the reports that that I've been
hearing that there are outfits out there
that that are not Kosher not legit
whatever uh that are pretending to be
recovery houses but are not or at least
are very shotly run or
whatever and and the fire marshal is not
going to approve those people they're
going to shut them down or make them
clean up their act and so forth and so
on so can you speak to that contingent
people who are probably not contacting
you don't want to have anything to do
with you because they're kind of running
a scam based on what I'm hearing can you
talk to that for that question so there
are there are definitely houses out
there that are running questionable
operations um and we know across the
country that we have to be concerned
about human trafficking we have to be
concerned about drug dealing we know
that in any industry there will be
people who will take advantage of a
situation if they can do that and this
is every housing is a place where they
can take advantage however there are
also very reputable houses out there
that have their own um
their own source of financing they have
their own means to get recovery
residents within their recovery house
and they have no need for the
connections that NH core can provide or
that the state registry system can
provide um they have out ofate funding
sources they may have out ofate
clientele sources there's no reason at
all for them to come forward and get
certified and they may run excellent
houses as well
they should be treated the
same they we all should be treated the
same and we should be treated the same
as any other similar type of housing so
another type of housing would be some of
those um houses that are turned into
apartments for un andh
same okay it just seems to me like the
fire marshall is going to be what I'm
concerned about is the Fire Marshall
going after the places that are unsafe
and unscrupulous and so forth I don't
think he's coming after you guys I don't
see it as a situation where they're
going to be discriminating but but
you're the expert so I'll defer to you
representative
Pearson thank you madam chair who who
sets the certification requirements that
you certify people under that's question
one they do thank you for the question
um the certifi certification
requirements are established by the
National Alliance of recovery
residences and that organization Nar is
recognized by the by Congress it's often
cited in federal reg regulations as
setting the standard for Best Practices
within the social model type of Recovery
House those regulations are how we
certify again it's a voluntary
certification so they do not apply to
Oxford Oxford houses and there aren't
Oxford houses in
Manchester they don't apply to anyone
that doesn't come forward to be
voluntarily
certified followup
followup are you on the board or is your
agency have a seat at the table in
Nar I attend monthly meetings with Nar
and I am on the advocacy board with Nar
so I'm involved in all the federal
legislation that um would affect
recovery
no okay representative laus um thank you
madam chair um so you said it's
discriminatory in that there's other
types of housing that are similar like
uh the apartments that are you know for
students and my question
is um you give me an example of a place
that a type of
housing that would not need um some kind
of exception from the fire
marshal to operate you know maybe I can
word this better so you're looking for
certain kinds of exceptions for the
recovery houses I one I know of as
sprinklers there may be others but is
there some other kind of
housing that um you know would want to
operate or would operate without
sprinklers or those other
requirements that wouldn't end up with
the same kind of
uh requirements that are in this bill
I'm looking for you know is there really
a case clearly of
discrimination could I defer that
question to Chris Wellington as she is
law do you what I'm looking for is an
example Le not an exposition on the law
better
Chris this is Christine Wellington um
and I'm a board member of New Hampshire
Corp um we could use representative
O'Brien's example of the um duplex home
and according to uh repres
representative O'Brien um because
they're they're single family homes but
because they're duplexes there the fire
code requires smoke detectors if that
duplex was a recovery home um our
position would be that yes the home
requires smoke detectors because that's
the fire code but it would not require a
sprinkler because the residents would be
this the same situation as um two
separate families living in the duplex
so that there shouldn't be any extra um
regulations placed upon a dwelling
merely because the occupants are people
in recovery um and are protected under
the federal fair housing act and by the
way the state law against
discrimination thank you representative
Alro um I think this question is
probably better for Mr pesi answer um
but anybody could chime in um I assume
that there are
differences uh in the requirements of
different structures and institutions
for instance hotels versus U multiple
dwellings and that sort of thing um and
uh so the type of structure and many
other factors play in to the discretion
that's used by the fire marshall
discretion or as uh might be worded
discrimination uh used by the file
because discrimination is not a bad word
implicitly uh that discrimination so my
question for Mr pricey or for yourself
is is that U
discretion not well warranted in the
fire Marshall's decisions
to um make different have different
requirements for different structures
and institutions
establishments Mr
pery thank you madam chair thank you for
the question sir um
so the short answer is yes absolutely
there are different requirements
depending on the number of people that
are in the building the type of
structure the number of floors the
number of exits all of that plays into
what the requirements are going to be I
think one of the really important parts
about this this entire issue is
that we we came to this we got to this
point at least I think we got to this
point because the the folks that are in
recovery housing are disabled and
therefore deserve it of an a reasonable
accommodation and if they're deserv it
of a reasonable com so so ordinarily the
way our posture is that because of the
type of housing the type of structure
the number of people in the house or
building uh the number of floors exits
and so forth often times fire sprinklers
are
required what we were tried to do or
what we're trying to do with this
legislation is simply say we recognize
that a reasonable accommodation should
be granted to these people so therefore
we figured if we can mitigate some of
the risk of a fire we can
therefore grant them the reasonable
accommodation from the sprinkler system
and still put a head on the pillow at
night knowing that they're going to be
relatively safe I I think that's it in a
nutshell I hope that answers your
question if not I'll certainly be happy
to follow up thank
you other
questions Roy and then represento I have
a question for fire M pery can you speak
to this this allegation for lack of a
better term that this is somehow a
discriminatory
policy thank you for the question
representative
I I am I can't and I can't because what
we're trying to do is lessen the
restrictions not increase the
restrictions I I know it's it seems like
it's getting turned around but we're
simply I know it's a laundry list of
things but the important part to
remember is that that laundry list of
things only needs to be done if the if
the if the occupancy is requesting
relief from an automatic fire sprinkler
system if they're not requesting that
this none of this comes into play
now uh director box list comes into play
because if they're going to be certified
certainly they need to follow that stuff
but other than that we don't really get
involved if they're not requesting an
exemption or or reasonable
accommodation follow up um
so they've said that similarly situated
buildings that may house for example
students or or what have you are not
subjected to these requirements
so are they subjected to the to the um
fire sprinkler
requirement yes sir they would be and
and and to just to add on to
that I don't use this in a in a flip way
but if an outlaw motorcycle gang came to
us and said hey we want to you know not
put sprinkles in our in our clubhouse
but we're going to have 12 or 15 people
sleeping there we would like not
entertain them because they're not
disabled they they don't they don't they
not deserve it of a reasonable
accommodation folks that are Sub in you
know have suffer from substance use
disorder and in recovery they are
deserving of that accommodation so
therefore we're trying to Grant relief
not create more of a burden thank you
committee represent Gro did you still
have a
question
thank you madam chair representative Roy
asked my question actually I'm I'm all
fine thank
Pearson as did you hear anything I just
said
no uh looking at the attendance list
here we have the fire chief of the city
of Manchester on uh the attendees list
and I think it would be for the
committee to hear what's going on
specifically in his City in reference to
this issue well I was about to ask for
for if anyone wish to testify but your
goonan
Chief you have to unmute yourself here
we go I'm I'm back I'm back I just I
lost it for a second here um yeah uh I'm
sorry I came on a little bit late we've
had some a couple issues here in town
that I couldn't get to the uh the
meeting in time but I appreciate you
letting me let me speak um yes uh I I
fully support this bill uh we've been
working on um this type of legislation
um for a long
time uh every time I speak in front of
um a hearing or a committee um it it
boggles my mind
to think how far we came away from the
traditional requirements of the fire
code to get to this point we're truly
trying to make this easier uh to get
some of these um buildings in and um
like the fire marshal said we still want
to sleep at night we just want a a place
that's that's reasonably safe uh for uh
people you know I always say even a
protective protecting class deserves to
sleep safely at night and uh you know
some of the places that we see certainly
are not safe um that's what keeps us up
at night uh so um to to say that we're
we're purposely trying to discriminate
discriminate discriminate from a a
protected class just blow my mind we we
don't discriminate we treat all these
buildings the same whether it's um uh
whether it's a rooming house or whether
it's uh uh folks from SS snhu uh
occupying a single family home um you
know it it's I totally understand uh
sober living I totally understand what
uh you know the the opioid crisis and
the drug crisis and the methamphetamine
crisis and the alcohol crisis and the
everything above crisis I get it I'm
150% in the middle of this thing you
know I serve on some national committees
the National Institute on drug abuse uh
we speak about this all the time I am
100% in I just want people in my city um
in in the of course in the state to to
just have a a safe place to go they
deserve a safe place to go um when
they're in recovery that's that's what
the the basics of this whole thing and
uh with the help of the fire marshal
we've come a long way uh to meeting
we're we're well past meeting halfway um
we're looking at you know we've always
wanted to do is just a quick check sheet
here you go you come in you just
identify yourself as hey look I'm I've
I've got this uh um a home it's going to
be a silver living home um we're on you
know one two3 debuk street and uh and
and we would respond by saying here's
your check
sheet that's it you know we're not
asking for a whole lot more than what we
ask for your typical uh person with a
with a three family um we've seen a lot
of Bad actors I understand that uh that
n and New Hampshire core um you know are
working hard but you know you know
there's no guarantee that everybody's
going to play by the rules alls we want
to do is have a a basic set of safety
rules um that we can help people in help
people that want to run these agencies
in these uh these homes um help them
open up uh not prevent them from opening
up uh you know that's that's basically
what we're coming you know what we're
where we're coming at this and and every
time I come up here I I just can't
believe it comes back down to always the
same thing if unless you play by our
rules 100% well there's going to be a
lawsuit you know that's that's really
what it comes down
to Chief I have a question if if I
understand you correctly you're saying
that you
support the requirements of this bill as
a absolute bare minimum accommodations
required for safety for living in an old
building that doesn't have a spring
correct yes yes um you know in I think
we're even we're going above and beyond
you know accommodations for I we're
looking at
um trying to cut a piece of the fire
coat out just for these these folks that
are um you know are are suffering from
you know substitute disorder um but we
really treat all the places the same I I
think this is this is a good set of
minimum standards instead of dealing
with recovery houses specifically we
should put into the fire code that you
know this is not recommended but it is
the absolute bare minimum if you want to
live in an old house with a without a
system because that's what you're trying
to do if I understand correctly
yeah yes living in an old house without
a sprinkler system you're asking me if
this this would be uh kind of a minimum
standard I would agree with that okay
thank you that's what I wanted to
clarify that in my own mind other
questions representative scitech
uh uh your approval list Chief goonan
does it insist or does it say that they
can't
sorry well I think that's that's one of
the things that do keep us up at night
um you know I think you you you'll find
it statist statistically there's a lot
of folks smoking in some of these
buildings and we have an awful lot of uh
tragic fires Rel reled to that I can
tell you I rolled in on a few of them
myself alone uh this spring so yeah it's
it's um it's something that we deal with
especially in the larger cities yes
thank you other questions one more
follow Chief G I'm not sure this is for
you it's maybe for uh Fire Marshall
paresi but I want to summarize or try to
summarize as the chair did just a moment
ago if there are any discriminatory
aspects in this it is because you are
trying to make reasonable accommodations
for the disabled under the Americans
statement I if you're asking me I think
it's a fair
statement and thank you I I hope Chief
Fire Marshal pesi would agree yes I
would representative scitec thank you
for thank you for the question
representative
sh thank you madam chair um my question
is for chief goonan um I think what
representative Pearson was hoping for
would be an example of what you are
seeing particularly in your city uh as a
needed well I think in my city um we do
have a a quite a few in fact um this
week seemed like a a big week of um
local residents identifying uh possible
um buildings that are sober living
buildings but yes we see kind of all the
above uh we have some really good folks
that are um are in here in they'll for
instance we have we work with a few
groups who will come to us first and say
Chief uh in in Fire Marshall paresi it's
the same group that that he sees a lot
help us help us um open up help tell me
what you need for minimum standards so
we have a lot of folks coming in here
Meeting those minimum standards but
because you don't have any any uh
definitions or or any uh let's say
regulations besides having identifying
people as rooming houses you know we
come go in there and say unfortunately
you did a fantastic job with this
building but because we have nothing
else you're a rooming house you need a
sprinkler or I have nothing else to do
but take action you know what I mean it
it's we're looking for some guidance in
some um kind of relief because we don't
want to do that to folks that are that
are um you know operating these these
buildings that are um that we think are
you know relatively safe and they're
upfront and honest with us you know and
and following uh New Hampshire um core
and Nar and those folks because those
are those are good um but uh we also
have people we you know I'll be notified
by my uh my officers as they go into
places hey chief do you realize you know
we have you know 30 people living in a
three family you know and we're like we
don't know and then we'll have to try to
start taking some action and and uh you
know that's what keeps us up at night
because we just don't have any we don't
have any clue where these places are and
we're not asking for a lot we're not
we're not asking for you to come in and
and and pay a fee we're not asking you
to come in and say you know you're got
to buy a$ th000 licensing fee so we're
going to go inspect we'll help you open
up we'll we'll touch Bas with you the
next year or we'll you know I'll send a
a fire company over just to do a quick
check sheet make sure everything is
still operating and uh and the fire
chief in Manchester you know can sleep a
little bit better at night that's simple
than thank
you represent
Alro no I didn't have a question oh okay
good repres
Pearson thank you madam chair and thank
you Chief goon for uh for coming before
the committee today and testifying your
your leadership in this has has been uh
has been very helpful you just touched
upon an interesting uh concept of of
knowing simply knowing where these
locations
are that becomes
Paramount or do you think it becomes
Paramount even in the smaller rural
communities and not just in the city of
Manchester where we have uh
substantially more fire
resources I I do because what a lot of
stuff we do is is is pre-planning and
and we we want to know our neighborhoods
our our our officers and our
firefighters uh want to know what
they're um what they're uh arriving to
um and a lot of times when you if you
arrive to a place that you think think
uh you know may have uh you know three
people in or a building that's uh on
fire and you expect your normal you know
three family with three four people in
or even a family with five people or
something like that and then all you you
show up and you got 10 people per floor
that's a problem for us and that'd be a
problem for any place in the in the
opinion thank you are there other
I'd like to thank everyone who came back
after we had to adjourn
I very helpful what's that go oh
representative
goalie thank you madam chair I don't
want to ask a question I was a
co-sponsor so as a co-sponsor I just
like to speak briefly at the end
here if I
may um I just want to talk about a few
points we heard earlier um about
from New Hampshire Corp um it's an
organization these
recovery uh places are not required to
register with them um they're an
organization that goes around certifying
the ones that they certify but it is not
a requirement to be a recovery house
here in New
Hampshire
um also want to note that it was noted
about UNH housing not needing sprinklers
that's not true they would need
Sprinklers and
this bill gives an exemption to recovery
houses from Sprinklers and so I'm not
sure how they think they are being
treated at a higher level when it's
actually giving exemptions for um the
law and you know this this eliminates
the need for for
sprinklers um working in Manchester you
know we I did see a number of places you
go on to call for a smoke detector
activation
you show up to a three family expecting
six or seven people in that building and
you get 10 or 12 coming out piling out
of
rooms to be reported to our fire
prevention when they go and find out and
they say they're a recovery
house um I think it's important
that these added safety
measures are adopted and required if
these are going
to um work as it be a recovery house um
the the other thing I did want to say is
in speaking with
uh Fire Marshall
exceptions but the issue is that goes
back on him when something
happens and someone gets injured or
killed because he gave an
exception whereas if we as legislators
put it in statute gives him a little
breathing room at night not knowing that
it wasn't on him it was in the statute
and it's how we felt these places should
be
treated um and and I agree with him on
that I I I truly agree that if he wanted
to or if it was someone else in his
position they could go around and say
they're not giving the exceptions and
could say you know fully go by the fire
cat and put everything in so I hope the
committee will uh vote this all to pass
and that's all I have to say thank you
Jake Barry had asked to testify and he's
here so if he would I recognize
him thank you thank you madam chair
honorable members of the committee uh
sorry let me turn on my video here um my
name is Jake Barry I'm the vice
president of policy of new Futures as
many of you know new Futures is a non
nonpartisan nonprofit Health policy and
advocacy organization we've been working
for more than 20 years to address
Alcohol and Other Drug issues in the
state I'll be brief I know you've
discussed this at length today uh new
future is not taking a formal position
on this bill but I do want to emphasize
the sensitive and important nature of
the issues around recovery housing I
don't I know I don't need to tell you
that access to stable housing is one of
the most critical factors contributing
to long-term recovery from substance use
disorder and a lack of housing
facilities is one of the biggest
obstacles we face as a state in our
battle to overcome the ongoing addiction
epidemic I certainly recognize that this
bill is intended to help ensure the
safety and security of our recovery
housing facilities and and certainly the
Safety and Security of these houses and
their inhabitants is Paramount uh that
said the risk of fire or other
emergencies is not the only concern
facing the individuals uh in these homes
as they seek to achieve long-term
recovery uh so I really want to thank
the committee for the work you've done
today and and I hope you'll continue to
ask tough questions and and dig deep to
ensure that there are not any unintended
consequences of this legislation that
could lead to the overregulation
financial strain or unnecessary closure
of these houses uh again we certainly
appreciate your attention these critical
issues and we're happy to work with all
parties to uh to to find something that
works and thank you I'm happy to take
any
questions thank you are there
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you is there anyone else who
testify I don't see anyone so why will
and open the hearing
on House Bill
not not cheering the meeting but I don't
have any place to move
to
okay we're opening the hearing on House
recognize
M thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm Carol Maguire representing
the towns of Allen toown Epsom in
Pittsfield marac District 29 house bille
369 was a request of the
oplc and in fact after
the occupational therapist board
reviewed it they came up with an
amendment number 2021
0185 which you should have
already which replaces the entire
bill and I defer all questions to the
oplc I believe miss Tom brck is their
afternoon I recognize Mr broadrick to
bill
we have a copy of the amendment some it
number Mr chair could I just ask a
clarification
sure um the amendment that we got at the
bottom says the bill is a request of the
office of professional lure but I
believe I just heard the sponsor say
that the amendment was actually put
forward by the individual board is that
correct yes the board recommended it and
it's put forward by the oplc the board
is part of the oplc I realized that I
just wanted to be sure the source of the
youc okay okay Mr brck you
recognized good morning members of the
committee or good afternoon I'm sorry I
was supposed to speak with you in the
morning um so I'm Tom broadrick legal
council at the office of professional
liur and certification or oplc um just
for the record the oplc provides
administrative and clerical Support
recordkeeping Services in business
processing for the approximately 54
licensing boards commissions and
councils under our umbrella so this bill
affects both oplc and one of the boards
we administer um the occupational
therapy governing board uh I want to
make clear right now I'm speaking on
behalf of the oplc the agency only I'm
not speaking on behalf of the board um I
believe there's someone here from the
board who's going to be testifying today
I'm not sure though with a change in
time if they're still able to do so um
So currently without this bill if
occupational therapists or OTS or
occupational therapist assistants or
OTAs wish to perform what are called
physical agent modalities or pams you'll
probably hear these terms thrown around
they must first obtain a cert
certification from the board before
doing so a Pam certification so this
bill will remove their requirement for
OTS and OTAs to obtain that
certification before they can perform
the pan
so what we're doing here is really we're
removing a level an additional level of
certification uh the bill was introduced
last legislative session uh it was
sidelined due to the pandemic it was a
Senate bill it passed through the Senate
but I believe it was tabled in the house
due to the pandemic um the OT board had
requested of oplc that we put forward
this bill again um and and so that's why
we did the oplc is in support of this
the the bill in our view it'll save
staff resources while also adequately
protecting the public so the bill will
save staff resources because there's
there's just one going to be one less
type of certificate to issue um less
applications etc for the agency to track
in the board to Grant or deny um we
believe it still adequately protects the
public I think there's likely some otes
here who can testify more as to the
actual practice of physical agent
modalities better than I could but I'll
note that the board still retains some
rulle making authority over the practice
of
pams with regards to the amendment um so
oplc are our agency we're not taking a
position for or against the amendment um
the amendment would further clarify the
board's rulemaking Authority regarding
pams which I'd be in support of in my
role at the oplc but the other two
changes have more to do with the
practice of Occupational Therapy rather
than lure requirements or
Administration um and for that reason
oplc isn't taking a
position um that's all for of my
prepared comments but I'm happy to take
any
questions any questions from s
BR I do I'm not sure if he's the best
person but um I'd like to get at least
some idea of the sorts of things which
are um whatever the term is the the
modalities I mean I was aware of
ultrasound and the electrical but you
know what other things are there yeah I
I am hoping that there are some
occupational therapists on to testify as
to more specifics I as I said I know a
board member was planning on being there
my understanding um as an attorney you
know and I have 54 boards I work with so
I don't know everything about all the
professions um is that these are um an
OT or otaa can perform these um some of
the modalities that a physical
therapists would normally perform so
long as it's uh in the course of them
providing their OT treatment um so I
don't know exactly um what those are but
I did I just received an email saying a
board member is on and um Can testify
more to that thank you who who is that
board member um Sarah I don't have the
last name inkley yes
yep any more questions from Mr
bradrick
okay read none I'm going
to recogize
Sarah
missley
Miss
there
I see her I just see her y yeah I see
m is there anyone else wishing to speak
Miss
us oh she's putting in her
now
can Mr brck maybe contact her
uh um I reached out to our board
administrator to see if I can help thank
you thank you it was just a a thought
signes now she's muted herself you're
good afternoon members of the committee
I apologize uh for the technical
difficulty I had been listening in on uh
Tom's testimony um and then had tried to
speak and and was unable to through Zoom
so I apologize for the uh delay I had to
dial in um via the telephone so my
apologies thank you for your
patient okay go ahead with your
testimony thank you you uh good
afternoon again members of the committee
I am testifying today in support of
Health Bill 369 you should have also
previously received written testimony
from Olivia R Freeman chairman of the
occupational therapy board I am an
occupational therapy member as well as a
board member with 14 years of experience
this proposed bill will allow OT
professionals to practice to the full
extent of our licenses and our education
the need for an additional certification
as it stands does a great disservice to
our profession the patients the clients
and all populations which we seek to
serve OT is a holistic discipline which
attracts many people to this profession
the treatment of skilled occupational
therapy with the use of physical agent
modalities also known as pams can
promote greater quality of life improve
patient outcomes and in many situations
decrease pain there are only currently
approxim imely a dozen other states that
require additional pams certifications
the state of New Hampshire being one of
them the elimination of the additional
certification would allow for
streamlined licensing requirements to
protect public health and Public Safety
and interest and may uh and may provide
indeterminate cost savings associated
with the elimination of staff and board
time to process the request for
additional
certification in closing the
occupational therapy board nously
much thank you there any questions from
Miss Hanley
no anyone
else okay there being none thank you
missley thank you testify this
bill I see no one I'm G to declare this
hearing
closed